okay
all right good evening everyone and
welcome to this meeting of the council
at first may I remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room
if the alarm should if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by the by following the five fire
exit signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
to do so that it's safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the Hall of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
we have a very full agenda of business
to consider this evening and we must
leave the premises before 10 o'clock
this evening
therefore I ask and encourage all our
all counselors to ensure that their
questions and debate are succinct and to
the point and not a repeat of others
questions and comments
to ensure that we get through all of the
items on the agenda I will allow a
maximum of 45 minutes for for questions
and debate on each substantive item
whilst at the same time ensuring that
the debate is fair and not curtailed
it is my intention to take a 10-minute
break at approximately two hours from
the start of the meeting
I would ask all counselors to ensure
that they return to the chamber promptly
thereafter
can I also remind you all to speak
directly into your microphones and avoid
putting any papers or other items in
front of them when speaking
thank you
I will now move to the agenda and the
first item on the engine is apologies
for absence
thank you chair I have apologies from
councilors Carter
Otten Passmore Phillips scarf and Turner
thank you thank you
and item two uh they need Declarations
of Interest by councilors
there are none
then we move to item number three item
number three is paper MC slash 21 7 to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 24th of May 2021 for accuracy
only
are there any issues any issues with
accuracy
councilor Weller
thank you Chad uh just a question really
um on page 19 uh my sub on the Suffolk
policing crime panel it states here that
the sub is councilor Sarah Manzo which I
think is correct however the County
Council seem to be
still inviting councilor Terence Carter
so if that could be clarified I would be
grateful please
thank you councilor
so we're good to go yeah all right so uh
we're bearing that in mind could I have
a proposer please
councilor Gould
and could have a second there
councilor Caston
okay I will now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the vote
thank you chair um on this occasion we
are going to take a hands up vote
um consensus vote so all those in favor
please if you could raise your hands
that's carried
takes us on to item number four uh paper
MC slash Twenty One slash eight
Chairman's announcement
um as you can see I've attended a few
functions and I was delighted to hold my
own function which was a barbecue at The
Cedars Park Community Center in stone
market and I'm Julie grateful and thank
all the people that were able to make it
and indeed for those that didn't make it
and contributed and donate it thank you
very much indeed you'll all be pleased
to know that we raised uh over 550
pounds on the day so thank you very much
I will now move on to item five on the
agenda which is the leaders announcement
I would like to invite councilor Morley
to present her update
thank you chair due to the length of the
agenda tonight I'm not proposing to go
into any leaders announcements
um everything that we've done over the
last few weeks has been fully circulated
amongst your and if any of you have got
any questions then feel free to email me
and we'll answer them out at the side of
the meeting
um thank you chair thank you councilor
Morley for that
um I wanted to ask about the Afghan
Refugee situation that the home office
has taken over the Cedars Park Hotel and
I wanted to know what locals can do to
support these Afghan refugees apparently
moving in well everyone's moving out on
Friday so they'll be moving in soon
after what support is mid-suffolk
planning to give to the Afghan refugees
and Stow market and for the people
who've been told to leave Cedars by
tomorrow those people that are sort of
living there as in they've got um you
know they might live there in the week
because they live elsewhere but work in
Stone Market um support the council can
give them to find further accommodation
thank you very much
thank you councilor even
um yes there is
um something underway yeah the location
is confidential and should not be
mentioned in public
um just because it is in social media
elsewhere doesn't mean that we should
also be mentioning it but I will ensure
that everybody's updated with the
relevant information as soon as we get
more notification from the home office
thank you very much
thank you
uh that takes us to item number six
which is to receive a notification of
petitions in accordance with Council
procedures
okay we'll then move right along to item
number seven questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure rules
okay my apologies uh should be questions
by countless in accordance with Council
procedures rules so we have some
questions that have been tabled so can I
I would like to read the question from
counselor Autumn as she's not here today
so bear with me
and the question from councilor Orton is
as follows
the menopause is a natural stage of life
but can lead to long-term changes in
physical and emotional health for women
including transgender
it is rarely discussed what support does
the council and its Partners have in
place to help and advise
that is a question from councilor Orton
I would like to invite councilor Morley
to respond
thank you
there is guidance on connect which
details how we can support women through
this stage in their lives the guidance
also offers tips and support from our
people the employee assist program which
all staff and counselors can access has
a section in that
provide guidance in support
as with all guidance we do review and
whilst this is comprehensive it is one
we will look at as part of our policy
and guidance review
thank you councilor holding
I'd like to then move to the next
question that have been posed and that's
from councilor mellons councilor Mellon
thank you chair
um
the question is this this Council
declared a climate emergency in July
2019 and is making progress towards the
goal of being a carbon neutral local
Authority by 2030.
however this will be through time
futosh and in carbon emissions from all
sources in the district
given the recent code red warning from
the ipcc and the urgency of this task
what measures is the administration
taking to encourage everyone in
mid-suffolk residents homeowners land
owners businesses and all other
organizations
to reduce their own carbon emissions
with the aim of achieving Net Zero by
2030. thank you
thank you counselor I would like to
invite councilor Morley to respond
councilman melon and I'm glad that you
agree that we're making progress we have
just switched our waste Fleet to
hydro-treated vegetable oil
immediately reducing its carbon
emissions by 90 percent the very first
rural Council to do so
we're installing a solar car port at our
mid-suffolk Leisure Center in Stone
Market enabling electric car users to
charge their vehicles but also to
capture clean energy for use within the
Leisure Center
results of the extensive mapping
exercise undertaken with the suffered
Wildlife trust to understand our
habitats and
Wildlife corridors in our district
we're offering free trees and hedgerows
to towns and parishes and have seen a
fantastic take-up of this
again increasing the infrastructure for
our biodiversity
we are a community leader in this space
must encourage and influence our
communities by setting an example
but our biggest message is simply make a
conscious change
small as it may seem not wasting water
not wasting food stop using Plastics
avoid the car where as possible and
switch to a green energy tariff
but to to highlight just two areas where
we are specifically encouraging change
firstly our local energy showcase
businesses and Community organizations
are being urged to tackle climate change
by joining baber and mid-suffolk's first
ever Showcase Event celebrating
sustainability and green energy
the local energy showcase organized by
mid-suffolk District Council alongside
labor Council will promote how different
types of energy can be used by
communities and
to help reduce their impact on the
environment lower costs and contribute
to the fight against climate change
tickets which are free are now available
for the two-day Extravaganza at Western
Park
on the 21st and 22nd of October
the event is open to all businesses with
an interest in finding out more about
local Energy Solutions as well as
Community groups and parishes who would
like to understand and explore the
benefits of using local Energy Solutions
the local energy showcase marks the
council's recognition of a climate
emergency and their commitment to the
Suffolk wide aim to become carbon
neutral by 2030.
aims to inform and update visitors on
the latest in green energy
featuring keynote speeches from
specialists in the field
workshops as well as the chance to
participate in a q a session with a
panel of experts on a range of topics
the event will also feature a
Marketplace for green energy businesses
and organizations to Showcase their
products and services demonstrate how
local Energy Solutions can be installed
and used
and how switching energy supplies can
lower Greenhouse emissions and reduce
energy costs
delegates will have the opportunity to
network with and learn from leaders in
the fields of carbon reduction heat
networks and solar energy
practical workshops will include
understanding the concepts of becoming
Net Zero how to access green grants and
funding and how to reduce energy
consumption
I would encourage everyone to attend
this exciting and informative event
secondly I would like to highlight our
food Savvy campaign this campaign led by
the Suffolk waste partnership helps the
people of Suffolk reduce their food
waste and save money at the same time
52 000 tons of food gets thrown away in
Suffolk every year
about a third of our black bean rubbish
is wasted food
the food Savvy project teaches people
about planning a food shop storing food
Portion Control freezing sharing and
composting
we know for certain that each of us
changing our behaviors and making
environmentally friendly choices will
make the biggest difference to achieving
our aspiration of carbon neutral
neutrality
thank you councilor Morley councilman
would you like to ask a supplementary
question
I would Mr chair thank you all right go
ahead
very grateful for the the details of
that conference I've booked a ticket for
both days and I encourage everyone else
to do so
I'm sure she heard the prime minister's
speech to the UN last night where he
somewhat bizarrely contradicted Kermit
the Frog
sorry councilor Miller can you get your
coming to a question yeah I promise you
I'm not quite sure which of them is the
bigger Muppet
but we are going to have to start asking
our residents to start making difficult
choices in the years ahead about how
they live how they travel what they eat
and how they Heat their homes councilor
when will we as a council started
we've been going on for a while please
get to your question
Administration ready to provide the
leadership on this issue that
mid-suffolk needs thank you
councilor Morley
thank you
hello no I now like to move to the next
question which is from Council Australia
Council Springer
chair
grappling with the technology
it's not loading up as quick as it
should here we go
sorry chair
this uh this is not loading up sorry Joe
um
David uh councilor burn
um I think I can remember it
would you agree that uh that uh oh hang
on thank you what the portfolio holder
agree that we need to give back to local
communities a strong voice in local
housing and planning policies both to
ensure development is appropriate to
local need and to engage communities in
sustainable development
thank you
thank you yes thank you Council singer
as you know from our conversations not
just as part of the member working group
for the joint local plan but also from
the detailed conversations we had as
part of framing our council's response
to the planning white paper we share a
desire to see our communities having a
stronger voice in the planning process
indeed I have been developing a motion
to prevent presented the council that
would emphasize this very point
the draft of that promotion currently
States
this Council applauds the government's
desire to improve and simplify the
planning system encourage Greater
Community involvement in the plan making
process and provide increased importance
for neighborhood plans
to achieve this
this Council believes that planning
works best when developers and the local
community work positively together and
do so early in the process
to shape local areas and deliver
necessary new homes and related
infrastructure
it therefore supports the right of
communities to engage fully in the whole
planning process by
full use of digital technology
participation in local and neighborhood
plans and maintaining the right
to object to individual planning
applications whether they conform with
the local plan or not
now following recent changes to Cabinet
roles within government and the
subsequent news that Michael Gove is
going to pause the proposed planning
reform
I will be writing to him to make similar
points and to emphasize the importance
of community participation in the
planning process
thank you councilor burn councilor
Stringer would you like to ask a
supplementary yes I would and I'm very
grateful for your patience for my uh
Tech freezing it's now one Frozen
I do have a supplementary
I know with interest that you use the
words that you're writing to government
to ask them to simplify the planning
service and the planning regime but of
course the planning regime has been
simplified over the last decade leaving
communities to feel that they have less
influence over the system than they had
a decade ago so would the portfolio
agree that is this government best place
to give us back this power
uh councilor burn would you like to
respond yes thank you
not necessarily going to agree to
answer that question as you as you put
it but I do accept that what you are
saying about the simplification of the
planning system has
has eroded the the contribution that the
communities can can provide
um it may be that as a result of looking
at that motion again uh the one that I
the draft that I just read out to you
um the and looking at the development
has um
uh as I've seen it happen over the
course of the last few weeks on the
approach to the uh planning reforms
um I might well not include the word
simplify
and the letter to Michael Gove it that
is that letter has not yet been written
um but I uh as I say it will be drafted
all along similar lines the one I just
read out to you as a motion a
simplification element of it I think
you're probably right
um
it doesn't necessarily fit to to the
ideal of
of
increasing community
so I shall make sure that that is the
principal message and nothing
thank you I would like now to invite
councilor eberne to ask her question
thank you very much chair following the
local government Association General
Assembly meeting in July please can you
report to council what initiatives were
made then to support local government
involvement at this year's U.N climate
change conference in Glasgow cop 26. and
advise Council of the task force work
done towards net zero
in view of this what will mid Suffolk be
doing to specifically support the cop 26
work thank you
thank you I would like to ask councilor
Fleming to respond
yes thank you very much councilor even
for for your question about comp 26
which is um I think very pertinent at
this time
um
I just would like to give the council a
little bit of perspective about what the
local government Association General
Assembly meeting was about in July so
that um
you know you're not wondering what what
the context of this question is
um here the um this meeting
um
highlighted the work and the importance
of local councils in meeting our climate
change goals and I quote councils have a
significant role to play in technique
tackling the climate emergency they are
well placed to translate National
Climate Ambitions into into
transformative action through their
roles in and hear some particular topics
are pulled out by the LGA Place shaping
purchasing director of delivery managing
assets including social housing and as
communicators
and on that basis I'm just going to say
a little bit about what we are doing
under these headings and so in support
of the whole initiative of local
councils working for the cop 26
objectives and I'm proud to say here
that mid-suffolk is recognized as a
leader in environmental initiatives and
it's ahead of mods councils in this
regard
there are many areas where this Council
its actions are reassuringly consistent
with the priorities advocated by the LGA
leading up to cop26 which I've just
mentioned and which I will just make a
couple of specific references to under
Place shaping the council as the lead
local planning Authority has perhaps the
most potential to make positive changes
and given the expectations in the new
nppf about good design
and what development should achieve our
planning team is fully on board with
these expertise expectations for Change
and are considering her best to put into
practice the messages in the new mppf
through consideration of a local design
code and working with communities
these actions I would add are already
part of our carbon reduction management
plan in section 8.
purchasing one of the actions of our
climate change action plan is to review
procurement arrangements and adopt a
whole life costing approach we
understand there's a lot more work to be
done
as we address the more challenging
aspects of carbon management within the
supply chain
Direct Delivery by this the LGA implies
support for new technologies and putting
actions in place on the ground
the other district is leading in its
Innovations as councilor Morley has
mentioned
in a grander scale I hope that Gateway
14 and the anticipated Freeport will
enable the district to really show its
capacity to lead on an all-important
national scale Exemplar commercial
project
managing assets we're on the process of
assessing and investing and improving
Council assets and assisted housing
providing grants
and so helping those who need the most
and communication the district is also
actively involved with communities and
its own staff to increase environmental
awareness
regarding the task force for NetZero and
what we're actually actively doing
clearly none of us as far as I know are
attending
um cop 26 in Glasgow that there may be
some people across the the room who may
be
um but I will just mention that the
there is a dedicated local government
day on the 11th of November which is
part of
26 and the LGA is asking for a dedicated
chapter for sub-national governments in
the official agreement reached Adcock 26
and finally the LG is asking for a
commitment to be made by government to
empower local councils to work within
the updated nationally determined
contributions to the UN framework
convention on climate change
the LGA will have an exhibition stand at
cop26 for one day
the city's region and built environment
day that being the 11th of November
which is open to all councils in the UK
who are invited to participate by
sending photographs and a brief
description of innovative work that
their
sure thank you councilor Fleming
councilor Eben would you like to ask a
supplementary question please go ahead
thank you chair um thank you councilor
flowing very much for that I had um
expected to ask the leader if she is our
representative on the LGA assembly and
we haven't yet had a report from her
from that meeting in July in accordance
with the um protocol for outside bodies
but I appreciate your response and I
would like specifically to know if we
are at that meeting it was discussed the
Glasgow food and climate declaration and
UK 100 which is about energy which we've
just heard about
um will mid Suffolk be signing up to
those two protocols thank you very much
thank you chair
um yes thank you very much I will have
to get back to you concerning those two
protocols but I can say that mid-suffolk
is participating in the local government
um open day on the 11th of November
we're going to put forward some
photographs and a description of our HBO
project to the cop 26 exhibition
thank you counselor
um I would now like to invite invite
counselor field to ask his question
so many of the population after a visit
to hospital the treatment after some
sort of Health event required actions to
their accommodation
the process usually commences with
reference to an occupational therapist
who determines what adaptions are
appropriate then Works undertaken by our
staff
could you tell us how long it is
currently taking from this sort of
initial referral through the
implementation of the out of these
adaptions perhaps on average and as
maximum
thank you I would like to ask councilor
hardingham to respond
members will be aware that at the turn
of the Year Suffolk authorities
introduced The Living the independent
living service which now provides the
disabled facilities Grant service to
residents
present baber and Suffolk internally are
unable to report the length of time
individual elements of the DFG process
take some end to end
workers underway to introduce key
performance indicators that will be
recorded in the systems we use during
the first nine months of this year
officers have been prioritizing the
transfer of data from existing orbit
systems to our own alongside catching up
on the historic OT backlog we can
confident confidently advise members
this evening that the process of
administrating minor adaptations and
grants are currently completed in a
matter of a few weeks
historically for several years members
will be conscious that a significant
proportion of the DFG budgets were
unspent year on year however the outturn
for 2021 demonstrates the budget was
fully committed which is ensuring the
volume of works and performance of the
surface has improved rapidly and
significantly during the past 12 months
a course disabled facility grants will
vary in complexity and scale so it can
take up six months or longer your
question counselor field refers
specifically to hospital discharge in
addition to the independent living
service there are services within
Suffolk namely stepping home which
supports the process of Hospital
discharge and is aimed at reducing
housing related hospital admission and
delayed discharge
the projects has units of accommodation
in temporary house
temporary house patients who are in
imminent risk of hospital admission due
to their housing or unable to be
discharged for housing reasons the
performance of our independent living
service is being monitored by Suffolk
housing board at a county-wide level
where we expect to bring updates on
performance the overview and scrutiny
Committee in due course
thank you councilor Harrington councilor
Phil would you like to ask a
supplementary
I think councilor harringham covered the
supplementary I had in that quite
comprehensive reply I would point out
that a few weeks is a considerable issue
to such people
qualities adoption
so we've now moved to the next item on
the agenda which is questions by members
of the public
thank you chair and received
we will then move on on to the next item
on the agenda item nine
this is paper
mc21-9 this is the overview and scrutiny
committee report I would like to invite
councilor Willem to introduce paper MC
oblique 21 oblique 9 which is for noting
thank you chair I'll be very brief
this report covers three meetings one of
which had to be adjourned
The Joint Council reviewed its work
during the previous year 2020 to 2021
and came up with some recommendations
for improving how we manage our workload
do the current and the future years
key seems to be to increase the size of
the committee we've we've had to adjourn
a meeting when it came became in core
eight just this week we would have run
into trouble with similar similarly if
we haven't rushed to finish by one
o'clock
a joint overview and scrutiny we're
asked to consider four specific points
in respect of cifco a number of concerns
about past performance were raised and
concerns for the future however to avoid
discussion of a political nature I ask
these be left for the respective Council
meetings
The Joint Committee agreed that the
business plan was robust
and and areas left for future
consideration include the effectiveness
of kpis targets for sustainability and
possible shortfall in repayments these
matters May well be included in the
debate later this evening
the council also looked at the process
and timeline for the review of The Joint
parking strategy there are a number of
detailed suggestions were made and
they're listed in my report
to information bulletins were also
received and they're referred to in my
report as are the proposed work plans
members will note that work has
commenced on a review of rural transport
as requested at the last meeting of this
Council I'm happy to take any questions
thank you councilor Willem are there any
questions for councilor Wellen on his
report
councilor even
thank you very much chair with regards
to the work plan for overviewing
scrutiny I note that on the 18th of
October
um there is some work to scrutinize the
way the cabinet is working and whether
this works for the council will that
review include the suggestion from Weber
District Council where they're
considering the effectiveness of cabinet
versus a committee system
and my second question if I may share
please could the scrutiny committee
urgently look at the health provision in
mid-suffolk District particularly in
stowmarket in the surrounding areas
such as the current shortage of GPS and
issues with dental services which is
with increased pressure lately coming
from Housing Development thank you very
much
thank you councilor eberne councilor
Willem
uh yes thank you Council Reba for that
question
um I note that there was a debate about
cabinet and committee systems at the
baber council meeting and since then
there has been a suggestion that from
from my
um my colleague the chair of
baber over in scrutiny that's that's a
matter that we will have to discuss
um and just tomorrow we have a chairs
briefing when that is it obviously will
be raised and it doesn't seem sensible
that we have two different uh reviews of
the way that cabinet operates
um it's much better I think that we look
at the whole thing across both districts
the questions being raised in both
districts so yes I can't say that will
definitely be included in the work plan
but it will be considered tomorrow
in terms of health provision in
mid-suffolk yes I think we have we have
referred to a shortage of of GPS and and
also there's been reference to to
difficulty in getting Dental
appointments that is also a matter that
can be looked at when we have the chairs
and vice chairs reaches tomorrow thank
you
thank you councilor Willem um are there
any other questions for the
on that report
all right thank you
so that report was for noting only um so
we'll now move on to item number 10
which is recommendations from cabinet
Pro committees and the first part of
that item is uh in paper MC oblique 21
oblique 10 the annual treasury
management report for 20 20 21. I would
like to invite councilman Muller to
introduce this paper and to move the
recommendations in the report
I'm gonna
thank you very much chair
treasury management
2021 out turn report was discussed at
joint audit and standards committee on
the 26th of July
it provides details of investment
performance effects of decisions taken
During the period and confirms
compliance with the council's treasury
management policy
the covid pandemic and the impacts of a
global lockdown dominated 2020-21
start of the financial year saw many
central banks cutting interest rates as
lockdowns cause economic activity to
grind to a halt the UK government
provided a range of fiscal stimulus
measures the size of which has not been
seen in peace time
the vaccine approval and subsequent
rollout program are both positives but
there remains much uncertainty in in the
around the level of losses that Banks
and building societies will suffer due
to the economic slowdown
the bank of England held the bank rate
at 0.1 percent throughout the year but
the extended its quantitative easing
program by 150 billion to 895 billion in
November 2020.
the UK unemployment rate was five
percent in the three months to January
2021.
unemployment is expected to increase as
the various government job support
schemes come to an end
inflation has remained low over the
12-month period latest figures show the
annual headline rate of UK Consumer
Price Index fell to 0.4 year on year in
February below expectations 0.8 percent
and still well below the bank of
England's two percent Target
more specifically for mid-suffolk the
council was able to take advantage of
holding additional cash from government
grants received relating to covid-19
until they were paid out to support
local businesses this has increased
treasury investment activity during the
year
the council operated within the daily
bank account limits short-term debt has
increased by 19.6 million pounds
the council lent a further 19.3 million
to cifco limited and a further 600 000
to Gateway 14 Limited
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix C of the report
the investment in funding Circle has
reduced by 53 000 as unallocated funds
have been reclaimed and existing loans
repaid leaving balance on the 31st of
March as 162 000. the council was
compliant with the upper limits for
interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the year was done so in priority order
of security and liquidity over yield as
prescribed in the treasury management
strategy members should note that in
appendix C paragraph 1.4 table 4 Page 24
in the mid-suffic table there are two
figures in the 31st of March 21 balances
which have been transposed the ccla
balance should read 5 million and not 2
million and the investec balance should
read 2 million and not 5 million I can
confirm there has been no change in
either of the amounts invested in these
funds I would therefore like to propose
the two recommendations outlined on page
31 of the paper and I call for a
seconder
thank you
happy to second that chairman and if
members have any questions
um Catherine Steele and Rebecca Hewitt
are here to take any questions thank you
chair
thank you councilor Muller
um we're going to now move to questions
and debate and can I just reiterate the
comment I made right at the beginning if
you're asking a question ask the
question
we will have plenty of debate
councilor Mathison thank you chair yes
um just just one
um table
um 8.2 which looks at the the risks
um that are are we are exposed to
um the second risk is is the risk of
achieving poorer Returns on the
Investments and um that that is rated as
probable with a noticeable impact and my
question is why
given that risk
um do we not
um protect ourselves somewhat and reduce
the um
or improve increase the security by
um by divesting from the assets which
are invested in fossil fuel
um we at risk both the poor returns and
capital losses on that score if the
Investments become stranded assets
yeah
thank you councilor uh
thank you very much councilor Mathison
for your question could I ask either
Catherine Steele or Rebecca Hewitt to
answer that question please thank you
thank you chair thank you councilor
thank you councilor Mathison for the
question
um just to say that the investment in
fossil fuels is something that we had a
long debate about at a previous joint
order and standards committee when we
looked at the ESG policy and potential
ways that we could do better in that
regard in terms of divesting you will
see from the report that the the current
value of most of those Investments is
actually below what we invested so if we
divest some of that at this point in
time the council will make a loss so my
advice is yours your section 151 officer
is that we wait for the values to to
come up then we consider how we can
reinvest that but again it's something
that we had a conversation about at
joint audit and standards in terms of is
there a point that the council might
actually accept a loss to actually make
a different investment so that is
something that we are continuing to to
look at and investigate
thank you
um are there any other questions
counselor
yeah um
yeah it was my understanding that that
joint audit and standards committee that
the committee did resolve to
recommend that the divestment happened
so I understand the quandary of being in
a position where at the moment we would
lose funds but would that not be the
case
whenever we did it there would be some
penalty for for
transferring Investments and so what is
the uh
predicted time scale for
the council to be able to make that kind
of decision thank you
if I could ask this section 151 officer
to respond
and thank you for that question
um might need to go back and double
check the sort of the notes that came
from The Joint audience standards but my
recollection was that there was a
recommendation to cabinet for us to go
back to fund managers and ask them about
about potential divestments so I don't
think the actual decision was made to
divest I think the decision might be a
mean about trying to see if that was a
possibility but I'll certainly go back
and just double check the resolution
from during auditing standards thank you
yes no no I'm sorry counselor could you
but I was going to say we were looking
at it so I don't think the time scale
have been set yet
my apologies counselor uh councilor
field you have a question
going to delay things
um yes just to look at the uh the
performance of the uh ccla and
Schroeder's Investments on uh sort of
bottom of page 51 and the top of the
next page essentially caught a dramatic
difference there between the
ccla numbers where the value is dropped
quite quite a small amount and the
others have dropped quite substantially
I wondered if you the comment there and
if we're taking any action about that or
is that
Frozen hoping that they go up again
please
thank you chair and thank you for the
question
um as we know with markets things do go
up and down and are dependent on
economic conditions so
um different funds will have different
valuations at different point in time
and the ones that are fared worse I
think have got some Equity investment as
we know the equity Market does go go up
and down but over a period of time tends
to go up the setting with property over
a period of time you know property
valuations fluctuate but over the longer
term the valuations actually do see an
upward Trend so I think it is just a
reflection of the point that the
valuations were taken and what was
actually happening in the market so I'm
not taking any particular action as a
result of that but we'll continue to
monitor the position
thank you very much
councilor Willem
thank you chair mine's a very very
simple question if I could ask councilor
Muller to look at page 41 the very first
the very last number on the bottom of
that page not paying not the 41 but
above that
it looks to me as if the total borrowing
is 142 and a bit million
if we were to divide that by the number
of adults in mid-suffolk
what sort of number do you think we
would get I'd guess it's perhaps it's
about two thousand pounds I wonder if
the residents of Stone Market realized
that we have borrowed 2 000 pounds on
their behalf
councilman
um thank you very much that encountered
well and could I possibly ask the
Section 105 officer to provide an answer
to that question please
thank you
thank you for the question um just just
to say that a large proportion of the
debt that is in that figure does relate
to the housing stock of the council I
haven't got the exact split in front of
me but I believe it's around about 80
million of that 140 million relates to
the housing stock because when back in
2012 I think it was we took on debt to
actually keep all of the rental income
from our housing stock so a large
proportion of that is is
um through that through that particular
source so the rest of the the debt is
mostly to do with with sifco so that's
what the the general fund debt if you
like is based around and I'm sure I know
you've got another item on the agenda
tonight about about zip code and the
business plan so I'm sure that will that
will get some discussion at that point
thank you very much
are there any other questions
counselor
thank you chair
yeah it's um
the president of my understanding of
this is It's a book loss of around 12
million pounds
with respect to the sort of cifco
Investments
um my question is regarding buying and
selling property
is
is a strategy being developed
with regard to buying a solid property
and would that also incorporate looking
at change of use of these properties and
will there be sight of a second question
I'm afraid a risk assessment
with regards to this strategy
thank you Council of warboy sir
Catherine
the question perhaps I could actually
ask you to hold that question until the
the sifco conversation that we're going
to have later on the agenda because I
think it's probably more relevant for
that discussion rather than the treasury
management report if that's okay
all right thank you both
are there any Phil if there are no
further questions then we'll move over
to the debate
um counselors will only be allowed to
speak once and for three minutes only
and this will be timed
so uh who would like to start the debate
okay right no debate then uh councilor
Muller do you wish to add anything
uh no thank you
thank you very much indeed
so there's no need for us to conduct a
vote we'll move on
apparently we do need to we do need to
conduct a vote so I will ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
yeah so chair on the recommendations
those are now showing in blue if
counselors would like to place their
vote thank you
councilor Guthrie are you okay or do you
want me to
be going
thank you chair that is 26 4 and 2
against
so we have to take a little pause while
we wait for the relevant officers to
appear
right we'll kick off again so uh item
10B paper MC oblique 21 oblique 11
gambling act 2005 no Casino resolution
I would like to invite councilor Guthrie
to introduce paper M.C oblique 21
oblique 11 and to move the
recommendation in recommendations in the
report councilor Guthrie
there we are thank you very much chair
2019 the no Casino resolution was
requested by a counselor to be
considered by full Council in that year
full Council requested the committee
provided an Evidence base for full
Council to make their determination
on the 16th of August 2021 the Licensing
and Regulatory committee met
the decision from the committee was to
recommend that the full Council
determine whether to adopt a no Casino
resolution based on the evidence
contained within the report
if the council decides to reject a no
Casino resolution there will be no need
to debate this matter again unless the
Secretary of State increases the license
allocation under the gambling Act 2005.
key evidence within this report is as
follows
has the full allocation for casinos
under the ACT has been granted and
utilized Countrywide that's eight large
eight small and one Regional Casino
there is no provision available for a
casino license to be granted
it would need a suitable economic
climate and the political will of
government the Secretary of State to lay
legislation for a further allocation of
casinos
there would be a requirement for
mid-suffolk to bid on such an allocation
if another provision of casinos were
ever to become available
a further allocation is highly unlikely
to happen and in the foreseeable future
and central government are currently
tightening restrictions in Spector
gambling
the original concern regarding casinos
stemmed from a planning application for
the snow Aces which included plans to
have as Casino as part of the proposed
activities on the site
this application has since been
withdrawn and the new proposed
development in this area Valley Ridge
has removed all reference to the
provision of a casino
mid-suffolk District Council licensing
Authority have received no applications
for a casino when the 2009 act came into
Force to the present day
research has also identified that none
in the surrounding district and Borough
councils that border mid Suffolk Council
have adopted a no Casino resolution
mid-suffolk District Council have only
two betting shops and all other gambling
act activities are mainly awp machine
machines Amusement with prizes in
licensed premises and small Lottery
registrations
it's a decision that can only be made by
full Council and the recommendation is
at 3.1 followed by 3.2 okay
thank you councilor Guthrie could I have
a second here
second thank you
okay
we will now move to questions counselors
may ask as many questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question
counselor
sorry if I'm
being a bit slow but I don't really
understand this recommendation so could
you please clarify
because all it says is this Council
considers whether or not to adopt a no
Casino resolution
to my mind
surely what we are we are the council
are we not here to actually resolve to
either make a no Casino resolution or to
reject a no Casino resolution rather
than because all this proposal this
recommendation is saying is that we're
going to consider it so I don't really
understand what what I am going to be
voting on uh when it comes to that stage
so please could somebody clarify exactly
what we are we'll be voting on in due
course thank you
if you
if you don't
this resolution
then you reject the recommendation if
you want this resolution in this Council
then you vote for it it's as simple as
that
so I'm sorry uh just one moment please
Council of Ansel I think to get some
advice on this
thank you chair
um just for clarity counselors the
recommendation as it's written in the
report is not suitable for you to vote
on in its current form because it does
say consider it gives you two options
um but you need to have a debate first
so the process that we're going to need
to follow is that the council will have
its debate and then they'll need to be
some clarification from the Mover around
following that debate is the will of the
council to make a no Casino resolution
or to reject a no Casino resolution and
then we will amend the wording in the
recommendation you're going to be voting
on equally for uh 3.2
you're not being asked as a council
to decide that it doesn't need to be
voted on again that's in the statute so
it's to note that you won't need to
debate it again in three years time
thank you
so uh right councilor e-bone
thank you very much see how glad that's
clarified same question
um
what I was wondering is what is the
license does the licensing committee
have a view on one or the other
um and in the paper there don't seem to
be any
um details about the benefits of a no
Casino approach so to me a no Casino
approach means we don't have a casino
which is various health benefits various
gambling issues
um and so on and so forth but there
isn't any that's just my anecdotal it
doesn't seem to be any thing in this
paper
um and secondly counselor even what is
your question so firstly what's
licensing committee's view secondly what
is the benefit of a no Casino approach
and thirdly if an oasis is not
considering one anymore are there any
other organizations that are considering
a casino in our district thank you chair
thank you councilor counselor girlfriend
well I can answer the last one first
because it's it it said in the paper
there that no one has applied for it so
that's that one and I've forgotten the
other two I don't know
I wasn't at the last one but I think it
was a 50 50 split was was it not
yes it was a 50 50 split yeah but it was
on the Chairman's casting don't but I
wasn't there sorry and the other
question
well that's for you to decide but um I
mean
there's no need for one why have one
but that's just a personal view that you
have to look at it yourself
are there any other questions for the
counselor
Council Stringer yep thank you chair
don't want to re-rehearse that question
but councilor even asked if anyone was
considering developing a casino
you answered as to you said that no one
had applied
that's actually a different answer to a
different question uh can can I just ask
what does the center the paragraph 8.1
actually means because I'm really
struggling with what that paragraph
means so someone could explain that that
would that would be really really
helpful thank you
I'm just coming back at I can't look
into someone some of mine whether
they're considering something or not so
sorry about that I can't answer that
um and 8.1
um you were at the committee I believe
um
so
maybe I could help maybe we could get
the I could get the monitoring office to
shed some light I was just going to say
on that one yes please I'll
thank you thank you chair and uh sorry
Council Guthrie if I've jumped in
preemptively there
um cancer string I believe you're
um referring to the paragraph ahead of
the uh risk management Matrix
um that paragraph explains the the
closest link to any risks that are
contained within the council's
significant risk register
um so it's just providing a link back to
our significant risk as well as any
particular risks associated with this
report
sorry I really don't want to prolong
this I was expecting you to explain it
because that doesn't seem to be a risk
to me
if we decide not to adopt and as a
double negative which I hate
not to adopt a no Casino resolution and
a future casino application is granted
further risks may arise well if you
don't
agree a no Casino resolution anyone
would assume that you may be lukewarm to
the idea so how would that then be a
risk I don't understand I really don't
understand how that's worded sorry
well uh can you uh shed a bit more light
on this
yeah Council Guthrie
um I guess possibly we should direct
this to one of the officers
yeah Council Guthrie should we direct it
to one of the officers involved
um
I'm not really sure I understand the the
question is it possible to have that
again just so that I can fully answer
that counselor cancer yes of course of
course 8.1 says
that it's closely released related to a
business risk number 14 that we may be
perceived as untrustworthy and have a
poor reputation
if the council do not decide and and the
case that could arise according to this
risk Matrix is if we do not adopt a no
Casino resolution so I understand that
the no Casino resolution Falls
and then we get a future casino
application well why would that damage
our risk because we've said we've not
declared a note we've not declared a no
Casino resolution that would surely
someone a developer would assume that
we'd be and it wanted the idea and may
be worn towards it so how would that be
a risk to our reputation surely the
reputational risk would be if we adopted
a no Casino resolution and then granted
one in the future
okay
um
the way I'm reading it is if we decide
not to adopt it it's what the future
risks would be if when someone came to
us to apply for one so that's
potentially the risks that we are
putting the organization in if we were
to Grant a future application for a
casino
is the way I'm reading it
councilor Guthrie may I speak to the
motion or do we have to have further
questions are there any further
questions
and yes just a very quick one
um
so
I understand
making with regards to you know if
if we do decide not to adopt a no Casino
resolution the further risks key risks
may arise but what I'm struggling to
understand is why gambling being
perceived by many to be a negative and
have a adverse effect on individuals
becoming addictive lacking social
interaction Etc is considered to be too
unlikely
um so I wondered how this risk Matrix
was put together and actually shouldn't
that be free quite likely
[Music]
can I ask a licensing officer to respond
put together the report and we assessed
stick through all of this and they were
quite happy with the recommendation we
put forward
you have another question counselor
um I I don't but um
I'm not too sure how you know if
somebody did apply for an application
for a casino why it's unlikely that
gambling is going to be perceived as a
negative as a negative thing as an
upshoot of that
um
I'm I'm not sure
I think we're in danger of going around
in in ever decreasing circles yeah so I
think at this point uh councilor um
we've and I see lots of heads nodding I
think we should pause questions uh I
don't see any others and goes to debate
um so that said uh usual rules of debate
uh
uh right okay so counselors will only be
allowed to speak once for three minutes
and this will be timed and uh then uh so
who would like to start
so councilor Omarosa
sure
um
so despite there being some conflict
conflicting aspects to this debate
the evidence that I find most compelling
are the findings which show that
gambling casinos are associated with
putting greater burden on Social
Services which I'm sure this Council
will choose to avoid
this leads me to conclude that what
happens in Vegas should stay in Vegas
um
so I think we've got an opportunity just
to say you know this isn't for us so
let's do that
thank you councilor councilor Guthrie uh
thank you very much indeed um I think
sort of what we really need to focus on
is there are no licenses that will very
unlikely to be any licenses and if we
have to pass this resolution it's going
to be a cost to the council and at the
moment it's an unnecessary cost it can
always come back should there ever be
the government's desire to start sending
out licenses and everybody's starting to
apply for it so um I think it would
waste a lot of council time debate and
money thank you
councilor Humphries
Mr chair thank you um I concur with you
really
um the gambling commission written this
430 000 people affected from gambling
now effective means they're either poor
they've got no money because it's all
earning debts mental health issues
stress effects on the family food
everything
um I think this is a golden opportunity
to say no if this was the environment
we'd all be jumping up and down and
planting trees so this is an effect on
our people so therefore we should do
something about it and I get your point
Council go through that no licenses can
forward but they will or they might and
we need to have something in place that
prevents it so we don't have long
debates it's Crystal Clear on the way
we're going to go forward so personally
I'm totally against gambling absolutely
in every form I agree with you if you
want to do it get on the plane to Vegas
or go down to London I'm against it in
our district I think we need to protect
our residents from that threat gambling
I just can't believe that we're actually
not vote to to have a no Casino policy
thank you
counselor
thank you very much chair um I
wholeheartedly agree with um councilor
Humphries and councilor Morrison I think
that
I think it would look very badly on this
Council if we said we're open to having
a casino here and I think this is our
opportunity to say no I don't think you
know it would put the council in a bad
light I think it would be bad for our
reputation to say that we're effectively
encouraging gambling and even by leaving
the door open we're still effectively
saying well in the future you can come
come on down if the price is right so um
I think we should
um recommend a no council res no Casino
no council resolution photographer
let's all go home
I I think we should um vote for a no
Casino resolution and um I hope that
somehow we can change its resolution and
put that through thank you chair
thank you councilor uh councilor
Whitehead
thank you chair
um
to get me awake at night but I do have
more concerns when I my local Village
shop where I see people ahead of me
buying long strings of scratch cards and
lottery tickets then perhaps a high
roller gambling in the casino and I do
Wonder from this point of view where
would we stop would we do we then go on
to ban betting shops do we then decide
to stop the sale of lottery tickets from
Health Point of View do we decide to ban
the sale of alcohol in public houses do
we band the sale of fast food Outlets so
to me this is a slippery slope and I
just think um I I think we should not
have a no Casino
policy
um and see what happens
thank you councilor uh I believe
councilor field wanted
thank you chair
to Advocate we go with all the things
that councilor watch had once banned but
to be serious about this for a second
and the only application I know was uh
snow Asis in my ward at that time now
Valley Ridge I never had a great
ambition to go there and gamble
basically because of the what I perceive
to be the adverse effect on people it's
not always high rollers it's people who
are have relatively limited means but
who exceed them greatly in such
locations frequently in fact if you look
in the table under 8.1 there there seems
to be a whole list of the problems there
the first one says casinos do not revive
local economies and then in italics it
says I don't really understand this as a
risk which is interesting but the next
paragraph downstairs it could have an
adverse effect on local property the
next one talks about
gambling is perceived to be Bombay you
need to be negative there's a whole list
of things there which says this is
negative there's not enough demand for
it there are no licenses available so if
we're going to say let's agree to a no
Casino policy and uh that's the end of
the debate thank you thank you councilor
councilor Fleming
thank you chairman um
I understand this is a very confusing
um
paper and idea but actually
for no adopting a no Casino resolution
won't give us any more protection from
gambling than not adopting a no Casino
resolution
and that is
um it's hard to it's not clear in the
paper why that is
but
um as councilor Guthrie has said there
are very few gambling licenses issued an
asset limited number issued by the
government and they're all taken up
um they weren't at the time that
snowysis was originally conceived
um in the very unlikely event that
one of those licenses became free and
available and was applied for in Suffolk
we could at short order adopt a no
Casino resolution so that we wouldn't
have to entertain
a new casino if we didn't want one
however
if we adopt a no Casino resolution
tonight
we will
incur additional
paperwork bureaucracy and the need to
re- review that decision periodically so
I think the downside to adopting a no
Casino resolution is probably a small
additional cost to the council and as I
said there is no downside to not
adopting no Casino resolution
thank you councilor councilor Morley
um
yes like like councilor Fleming and
probably most of us here I am totally I
find gambling totally abhorrent
um
but this is not about that
there is no mechanism
for a casino to appear in our or anybody
else's district for that matter there is
no mechanism in place for that this has
been brought about by
as councilor Guthrie said in her
introduction the introduction of snow
Aces
and the proposal at that time that this
no Casino resolution be adopted now the
Mechanics for that mean that this has to
come back to four Council every three
years
with with those ongoing costs of doing
so
if we reject this
it makes no difference whatsoever
because there is no mechanism for a
casino to suddenly be applied for in our
district
all we are doing if you adopt this is
committing the council to ongoing costs
every three years to go through this
this cycle every three years
I will be voting against this
despite my
absolute abhorrence about gambling but
you know gambling online causes far more
hazards to my mind than anything that
could be before us under this motion
under this
thank you counselor uh councilor
Stringer yep thank you chair
um
just wanted to
slightly caution about saying never
governments can turn things around on
the head of a pin and I admire councilor
Fleming's confidence that we as a
council could turn emotion around really
quickly if we saw something that
threatened our livelihoods on the
horizon
the time scale of this motion
probably would lead you to believe
that's not possible
the so the threat is not imminental but
it is still there governments can change
their mind very quickly the current
government of the Secretary of State for
local community stands up in the house
of Parliament that immediately becomes
law
so it could happen could happen tomorrow
looking through the papers it said it's
evidence-based
finding evidence about casinos is not
terribly easy so I have trolled some
evidence that has been peer-reviewed
uh
and the evidence
suggests quite strongly that
casinos create local jobs but they're
mostly part-time low-skill jobs that do
not pull households out of poverty
the other warnings it gives you is the
opportunity cost to others that are
considering other forms of development
can be quite high so if you do have a
casino being developed even though the
government doesn't have a regime for
saying yes to one this is about a
developer working up a scheme nothing in
law stops you designing a casino even if
the government doesn't have a policy
mechanism at this current moment in time
it's the opportunity cost of others that
might invest in that area if someone
were developing a casino scheme
the current site where we had one muted
wasted
thousands of pounds
in applying for that casino element and
lobbying for that casino element to get
where
this is an invest to save model to stop
people in the private sector investing
in something as a dream that that may
not come to reality and that we would
reject in the end
part of the other peer-reviewed evidence
I found and this was most compelling
low-income households that gamble at
casinos spend more than double the
average spend in low-income households
on gambling overall
so I will be voting for
a no Casino resolution to give the
private sector that clarity about what
we in mid Suffolk expect and for once in
my life I can wholeheartedly 100 agree
with councilor Humphries thank you
thank you councilor so uh now councilor
Mansell
uh thank you chair
um I I think that this uh this whole
paper is difficult to follow because
we're actually talking about a double
negative we're we're saying um that we
don't want to adopt a no Casino policy
and it's actually quite difficult to get
your head around that
um and I'm still at odds as to what
we're actually going to be voting on
because as I see it we haven't actually
got a votable recommendation yet uh but
I too agree wholeheartedly with
councilor Humphries and Council Stringer
and councilor amarosan
um in that I I see I I see very little
reason to change what we've got now we
currently have I believe please uh
forgive me if I've got this wrong we
currently have a no Casino rule I do
vaguely remember
debating it in Council some time ago uh
and yes it may well have been on the
back of us an oasis application but
um we hear from councilor Fleming that
that it doesn't make any difference
because we can we can adopt one
um as soon as somebody threatens us or
or whatever to me that's still going to
be a cost
um and to do it at short notice
um may actually occur more costs than
just having it on as a as a rolling
program and yes um we if we decide to
have a no Casino policy today and we
have to discuss it again in three years
time
um so be it I I I'm certainly of the
opinion that we should continue to have
a no Casino policy and I've yet to hear
what I'll actually be voting on thank
you
thank you councilor councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair um I just
wanted to make a few brief comments um
the first is that I completely agree
with uh what councilor Morley has said
I'm similarly perhaps unsurprisingly
given what's on the agenda later
um completely fine gambling completely
abhorrent and would not want to see it
in our district
um what I think is important to consider
though is what's in the recommendation
in this report that says effectively if
we were if we apologize this is going to
contain some more double negatives but
that we if we do not uh pass a no Casino
resolution we will not debate it again
unless it becomes necessary because the
allocations are increased under the
Secretary of State and as far as I'm
concerned we've set out a very clear
position here now I can't imagine at the
moment anyone setting up and saying they
really want to desperately push for one
um for a casino but I think if if from
my perspective
if we don't need to pass this motion
then let's not I mean we could go and
list all of the things we don't want to
see in the district pass and go even
further than the list that councilor
Whitehead said we could go we don't want
to
Virgin Galactic Spaceport in mid-suffolk
but I don't think that's going to have
any tangible impact and so unless the
allocations are increased I just can't
see
um the purpose of this even though I do
understand the need to deter gambling in
our communities but I just don't see how
that how this is going to make any
meaningful impact in doing that thank
you chair
thank you councilor councilor Matheson
thank you chair yeah when Council string
got up to speak I was rather hoping he
was going to impart the wisdom of
previous councils on on these matters
because his history does go back quite a
long way on that uh if he can remember
um what we've done before because we've
certainly been here before
thank you counselor caster
and thank you very much Mr
um the council doesn't have a no Casino
policy in place at the moment
um
my issue with this is I don't think
we're giving up any control over not
having a casino but to um to say
anything defined as a casino would be no
good for this
um District without knowing what that
actually looks like I think
I I'm I'm not happy with doing that for
instance
um Council Whitehead said about the
national lottery if somebody said we're
going to have a national lottery and you
can it will you you put money in you've
got very little chance of winning
whatsoever
um is that a good idea or not a good
idea you'd probably say it's not a good
idea yet the national lottery has put
money into things all over this district
and all over Suffolk
um it's very debatable so to put a
blanket a a casino in or the definition
of a casino in any shape or form is not
acceptable in here I wouldn't want to do
that unless I could actually see what
that would look like because there are
certain things that we could control
over it just like we do with planning
like safeguarding issues we I could go
on to this computer and go on an online
casino
and spend an absolute Fortune all all
the families money and there's no
restrictions on me at all yet if you're
in a casino there are safeguarding
issues there are things that they have
to do a bit like a pub for instance if
you if you stop someone from a moment if
someone's in a pub and they've had too
much to drink they can be denied service
and they can be turned away if somebody
if there isn't a pub and somebody stays
at home drinking you've got no control
over that person's Behavior how they
behave with other people around them and
um and the the quantity that they drink
so I'm not a casino fan I don't think my
I counselor Moroso said about the Las
Vegas
um style Casino I for me that wouldn't
be acceptable but we don't know exactly
what would be on the table and um
why why would we why would we say a no
Casino rule without actually looking at
that the chances of it happening are so
sorry I'll wrap up are so slim but we
still have full control over any any
casino application that would come to
our RM District thank you thank you
thank you councilor uh councilor Wellen
I think
thank you chair
um I think it's unfortunate we're
comparing a casino with the national
lottery I think they're completely
different casino is a glitzy they
glamorize gambling they make it they
make gambling look attractive and fun
and councilman casting wants to see
what's on the table before he decides
whether or not we should have a no no
Casino policy we know what sort of thing
will be on the table we don't want to
see it so we need the no Casino policy
now thank you
thank you counselor
I I wanted a point of legal
clarification if I could
could I make the house sorry Emily we've
heard it said that if a if a project for
a casino came forward we could
immediately respond with a no Casino
resolution
if we choose to not vote for a no Casino
resolution tonight could we in three
months time have a no Casino resolution
given our second rule
um under the six months all you can't
revisit a decision however if a third of
the council requests that that decision
is Revisited and then it can be brought
forward so there is a means to do it but
you are right to point out that our
governance procedures would apply when
taking any further decision on the
matter
all right uh
has he not been already no counselor
yes
um I think the the issue here is is one
of perception
um gambling exists National Lottery
exists
for most people
uh of such on the lottery of the horses
is just fun but for some people for some
families the effects are devastating
it destroys careers breaks up families
and large People's Health
there are numerous bodies throughout the
country that advocate that Advocate that
we proceed with Extreme Caution with
regard to gambling and at present the
government is doing this it is very
strict about how many licenses have been
issued but these licenses have been
issued under pressure from developers
wanting to build casinos
uh developer see an opportunity for
building casinos
I think it's very important that we
put out the message that we do not wish
to see the escalation of gambling that
we do not wish to promote gambling on a
huge scale that we do not wish to profit
from gambling on such a scale because
that's what it would mean a developer to
bring forward a proposition that there
was a casino and the council let's see
yes we have rates we can make a profit
out of this we can our sell money we
have Community benefits at the expense
of people gambling in gambling The House
Always Wins
it's the casino owners who will be
making the profits if we as a council
wish to be part of that
then
that is an issue that may or may not be
debated in the future I think we need to
draw a line now in the sand that we have
a no Casino policy
thank you
thank you councilor
so we heard earlier from the monitoring
officer that we probably need to revisit
exactly what it is that we're going to
be voting on so I'd like to call on the
monitoring officer to provide advice
thank you chair my um suggestion would
be to the council is that the
recommendation is changed to read that
the council adopts a no Casino
resolution and then obviously if you
disagree with adopting the no Casino
resolution you would vote against and if
you want to adopt a no Casino resolution
you would vote for and that does mean
that the proposer and seconder would
need to agree to that change
if you wanted to reverse it and and go
the other way then you're going to be
voting on that double negative statement
which actually I think in terms of
public understanding of what you're
voting on it's much clearer to do it
this way so chair my recommendation is
that the recommend the recommendation
put to the council is that the council
adopts a no Casino resolution but we do
need the proposer and secondary to agree
to that change
um and if that is um if if that motion
is passed then 3.2 becomes irrelevant so
you won't vote on it
right
so councilor Guthrie yes very happy with
that thank you
Council Muller yes happy with that thank
you
uh thank you all I will now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct the electronic vote on
the basis of that revised recommendation
thank you chair that revised
record
councilor War boys are you able to vote
please
thank you that's just come
the Voting is as follows for the motion
that Council adopts a no Casino
resolution 16 votes against 12 votes no
extensions
so that is carried
okay so we're going to move to
item number 11
um so just kind of wait for some people
to be uh to come into the uh chamber uh
before we get started on that
right councilor so we are at item 11. uh
this is paper MC oblique 21 oblique 12.
capital investment in fund companies
sifco Capital limited business trading
and performance report for 2021 20 20 21
part one
I would like to welcome the following
people uh to this meeting Sir
Christopher Howarth chairman of cifco
capital Limited Henry cook director of
cifco capital
Nigel Golda
he's the director of asset management
and jel and one of our advisors and
Helen Rumsey partner at nsers and with
them is our assistant director for
assets and Investments and managing
director of Cisco Emily attack
so before we dive in uh I would like to
deal with this item in the open part of
the agenda if at all possible
so can I please ask members to refrain
from asking any questions that relate to
individual tenants and the associated
risks
if you wish to ask questions on those
details please can you indicate and we
will move into closed session at that
point before returning to open session
to vote on the recommendations in the
report
[Applause]
and I would like to invite counselor
Gould to introduce paper MC oblique 2-1
oblique 12 and to move the
recommendations in the report
you know let's start by echoing your
Welcome
to our guests our advisors
I'm very pleased to see them here
particularly pleased to see them here
um I'm also pleased to introduce the
report detailing uh cifco's Capital
Performance over the last 12 months
and the proposed business plan for the
for the next year
the business plan is a fundamental part
of Cisco's governance and ensures
accountability to its shareholders
I particularly uh value the contribution
from The Joint overview and scrutiny uh
Committee in June this year uh which we
which confirmed their view that the
business plan is is robust uh and they
express their confidence in in the
management of Swift care
at the end of the last Financial year
sifco had provided the councils with
close to five and a half million of net
income since its Inception in 2017 and
that delivering uh approximately about 1
million to this Council during the last
Financial year as we know whilst facing
unprecedented challenges as a
consequence of the pandemic and
certainly providing the council with
much needed income at this time
sifco was able to withstand the
challenges of the pandemic and continue
to deliver income to this Council and
this is a testament to the investment
approach and the strong management of
the sifco portfolio since its Inception
which has seen rent collection rates
above the industry normal Norm
the business plan identifies the
challenges of the pandemic are not
behind us
and takes a prudent approach to cifco's
financial management over the next few
years ensuring that the cipco portfolio
continues to provide income to the
councils to support the delivery of
services and projects locally as well as
creating a long-term Legacy for
mid-suffolk to benefit in the future
I would like to do
um before any other questions is is pick
out some key points in relation to in
relation to zipgo
investment sorry the council's
investment in sipco is now completed
with final sums being drawn down in
March Pacifico enabling the completion
of two further properties during 2122
the focus of the fund is to continue to
generate income and add value where
possible
's adopted a new sustainability focus
and Target
uh the rent collection as I say is held
up well with total arrears currently
equating to
3.35 of the rent roll
which is a 170k against a 5 million rent
roll
and there's a downward Trend in in
arrears of 185
000 in in June
tenant administrations uh not unexpected
in the current climate resulted in uh
300K of bad debt being written off
during the year
but sifco's made full debt repayments
during 2021 despite the challenges of
covid
colleagues will see and the reported
part of in the business plan as part of
Prudential Financial Planning in
response to covid uh cifco is seeking
the capability
um
to defer between six and thirteen
percent debt uh payments to the council
over the next three years
all sums will be repaid in full at the
end of the three-year period or added to
the debt
repayments will be accrued in council's
accounts an additional interest will be
paid for the Deferred payments which is
uh will be circuit at 50k if full
deferment is used
did make full repayments in June and
continues to do so in September
uh mid-suffolk and last year's received
net income of over a million pounds
and the total less income received by
the councils at the end of last
Financial year since 2017 uh is 2.86
million for mid-suffers
um
total
cifco pre-tax loss in 2021 of 4.58
million comprises 1.9 million of
acquisition costs and 2.4 million
downward adjustment in in values 2.4
million primarily relating to those
assets most by most impacted by covid uh
namely uh properties in in Harlow and
Link it
so total losses since Inception are
second 12.5 million uh comprising stamp
Duty and fees uh acquisition costs 5.4
million and Market reductions in value
of uh 7.1 million uh
these are book losses only realized if
the assets were to be sold and it is the
expectation uh in line with uh history
that property values uh will rise over
continue to rise over time whatever
short-term variations may be the case
um finally Capital Investments planned
during 2020 21 22 to add value improve
sustainability and improve re-letting
opportunities three of those projects
are now completed and re-let and will be
revalued uh next march
okay uh thank you again I'll I'll leave
it there and uh invite questions from
colleagues after
somebody has seconded me all right thank
you councilman I'll be happy to uh
second your recommendations associated
with your report so uh with that we will
move to questions
uh as usual counselors may ask as many
questions as they wish and please can I
urge you to be asking questions and not
doing a war on peace beforehand and
um who would like to kick off with the
first question
councilor melon
chair
should I do them one by one sure
okay the first one miss Suffolk has
invested nearly five million pounds in
equity into cifco can can the portfolio
holder tell us what this Equity is now
worth
counselor
many of these questions it's it's
appropriate entirely properly
appropriate that those questions are
referred to our our experts uh here
including section 151 officer and I'll
ask uh Emily ATEC to uh orchestrate the
the answer thank you
so uh Emily the floor's yours
councilors and so the equity element of
the um investment in these properties
is always 10 to the value of the
property and and so uh in in in the
current case uh the values have um
decreased by
um more than the equity that was
invested and such uh the equity
um is currently has a very low zero
value however
there are still the opportunity for that
Equity value to increase because that
Equity value will fluctuate in line with
the value of the portfolio so as the
portfolio increases in value we will see
that Equity value uh increase as well so
our expectation is that the value of the
fund will exceed the level of the
original investment within 10 years time
so you'll see that Equity recovered
within that kind of time frame
thank you councilman your next question
yeah I know that the cifco council
published late this year and were only
actually available 10 days ago on the
13th of September which I feel is not
consistent with public scrutiny can you
assure us this will not happen again
how many
thank you and so again the civco
accounts weren't published late they're
not required to be published until the
uh end of the year so they're actually
uh published ahead of the required uh
statutory timetables in terms of
companies house we do always Endeavor to
publish our accounts as quickly as we
can and I think we do so
probably much more quickly than a number
of other companies and we have had a
very extraordinary uh sort of 12 18
months
both ourselves and our advisors have
been working remotely and so I think
um the sort of
possibly two weeks later this year than
they were in the previous year I don't
really think that is a sort of
significant
um delay and certainly significantly
ahead of the the deadline for publishing
these Accounts at companies house
thank you thank you counselor yeah thank
you for that clarification
um
we note that um
the amount of capital expenditure that's
sifco's made to improve the estate is
000 in this current year which doesn't
seem to have been something we have had
to look at before is this going to
continue or increase in the future
so again we're reaching a point with our
portfolio where it is maturing slightly
so we are likely to see the need to make
further Investments within our stock to
ensure that we maintain its value and in
the case of the properties that we've
been investing in
um this year again many of those have
been affected by the pandemic and we've
taken this opportunity with those
properties becoming vacant to improve
those premises so one of the premises we
are improving roof and looking to
install solar panels on the roof as well
so we're taking the opportunities to
really enhance the value of those
properties whilst we have them vacant as
part of prudent management of any
property estate
you do need to continue to invest and
make sure you maintain the value of the
assets within the estate and we will
continue to review the portfolio and
plan works in a in a kind of prudent and
sensible way in order to protect the
Investments that have been made
thank you councilor melon and him
last one I promised you thank you
um it seems to me that the the strategy
of sifco is rooted in having access to
cheap funding but midsoffer is currently
funding 27 million of its investment on
a short-term basis
sure that can continue to fund this debt
at
over the coming years in the current
inflation environment which could lead
to higher interest rates thank you
to our 151 officer thank you
sure
we do have access to a lot of short-term
borrowing and we anticipate being able
to do that in the future a lot of our
short-term borrowing is between local
authorities and there are lots of funds
out there we obviously take advice from
our treasury management advisors Arlene
close about whether we're on short term
or long-term borrowing and we continue
to seek that advice to see if there is a
pertinent point in time that we might
want to take longer term borrowing but
their advice at the moment is with all
the current economic climate that it is
prudent at the moment to stay at
short-term borrowing so we are we are
benefiting from those lower rates
currently
thank you for your questions counselor
Millen counselor Willem
thank you chair I'd like to follow on
from some questions that councilman
asked he was given the answer that the
equity value is currently zero what
happens if it goes down
what if it reduces to below zero do we
have to do anything I mean
um and does the the fact that we have a
low Equity value affect any decision
making in any way
thank you and so the equity value can't
go below zero zero is the and the lowest
it can be recorded at and again
um the only
um the the council isn't required to add
any further funds into sifco because the
equity level is at that zero level again
this relates to the
um the sort of paper loss element where
funds have been invested
some of those funds
covered the costs of acquisition such as
stamp Duty and fees and and some relate
to the reduction in value of the the
fund but there is no reason why any
further sums are required to be invested
as equity and as I mentioned earlier
that Equity the value of that Equity
will fluctuate in line with the value of
the property portfolio so no there's no
further sums required and the equity
won't fall and below the zero position
uh councilor Mansell sorry uh chair my
second question was hasn't been answered
guys could you repeat your second
question then yeah does the low Equity
value affect the way that decisions are
made
see value does affect the way decisions
um From sifco's perspective
councilmanson
uh thank you chair I I've just got a
question for clarif clarificationally in
paragraph 4.11 on page 78 which follows
um on with some pie charts about the
split of the investments in as per
sector the paragraph
um refers to different categories than
the pie chart
it talks about the Leisure sector which
aren't mentioned in the pie chart and
the pie chart talks about Alternatives
so could I please ask some clarification
about what exactly is meant by
Alternatives and does that include the
Leisure sector or should they be in some
other category thank you
thank you and I'd like to refer that
question to Nigel Golda from slang laser
oh thank you Emily Nigel Falls yours
portfolio
yeah usually I can't explain why the
individual um
tax doesn't match the actual numbers and
we can seek to clarify that for you
later can I just come back it's not it's
not the text following the numbers it's
the text with the text
the text in the paragraph doesn't talk
about Alternatives it talks about
Leisure sector the pie chart makes no
mention of leisure sector I'm not
worried about the numbers I'm talking
about the actual
um it's inconsistent terminology is what
I'm worried about
Emily
thank you councilor um in terms of the
property sector and the the pie chart
reflects the uh the sectors that the
property Market would consider so
Alternatives is the um the sector that
would include the Leisure sector and so
that's why it's shown
um in the pie charting in that
particular way and I I can take your
comments for future reports if you would
prefer us to see Leisure represented
differently however from a property
perspective we always look at leisure
within that alternative sector because
we look at the more traditional sectors
such as retail offices industrial and
fall into those categories effectively
falls into the alternative category
to clarify what exactly Alternatives
mean if you're not going to refer to
them in a paragraph
noted thank you
so councilor field
just a couple of questions one of them
looking at the table above paragraph 12
just as a convenient place it talks
about total returns of uh just over a
million
1.017 total capital of 49.58 million uh
percentage return of 2.05
am I correct in comparing that with this
say the ccla figures that we saw
previously where the return was about um
4.3 percent I think Schroeders was
around 4.7 albeit at a substantial
Capital loss so that's the first
question
and again if I can refer that to
Catherine Steele 151 officer thank you
Parable figures because the the two
percent you're talking about in the
civco report is the net return and
likewise in the treasury management
report they were the net return figures
that were being quoted
thank you so we're taking a bigger risk
and making about less than half the
return
um this next question really is about
property values
in
paragraph 12 again it is really uh I've
tagged this against it talks about the
basically concept that that um we've
invested 50 millions or thereabouts and
there's a substantial loss so far in
fees etc etc
um and the assumption is that those will
recover over time so don't worry about
it counselors if you only wait for 50
years it'll all be okay
um I was really just in a question the
we've seen that we were invested in
retail properties we're fairly rapidly
stopped doing that for some obvious
reasons
um the things we're left with at the
moment was largely industrial but quite
a lot of office based and we all know
that offices there's lots of people who
don't intend to go back to the office
anymore so I was really questioning that
um is that assumption that values will
recover really
valid in in this case I don't nobody can
see the future but is there a reasonable
expectation perhaps I was thinking of
offices I think we had an headquarters
building once which became
unfit for purpose and of essentially
zero value so offices don't always
appreciate in value
thank you
thank you counselor
um in terms of
um
seeing into the future you're correct we
are unable to forecast uh into the
future however our experiences show that
um property values do tend to
um work in cycles and we do expect the
value of this portfolio to continue to
improve in value particularly following
the challenges that we've faced in the
last 12 or 18 months where we've seen
values that have been very depressed for
certain assets in terms of your specific
question
um regarding offices yes it's a very
challenging time for offices currently
but again I don't think we are
um through the evolution of the office
Market or office usage yet uh
still working from home and many others
returning to the office I think we still
have some time before we see the the
true outcome of the impact of the
pandemic on our use of offices in the
meantime our offices are
well spread in terms of the tenant
diversification and location and indeed
the lease length as well and
I'm happy again to perhaps refer this to
Nigel Golda from jll who obviously is
dealing in the property markets on a
sort of daily basis and and may have a
an updated view in this regard
Nigel
um thank you chair
um I think it's a very fair question to
ask it's a perplexing many investors
in terms of where the place capital
as a business we're still seeing a
weight of capital coming in both from UK
institutions and abroad
into the office sector so there's still
a turnover of Investments for that it is
tending to chase better Prime buildings
and also those that are well let
um so it's just tasting more annuity
based income than it is for secondary
buildings the cifco buildings are modern
they're well led to strong governance
rules so we are we're quite robust in
terms of current period and in fact the
first expiry is not until 2025.
so we will see the other side of that
equation as we go through and the other
part of the equation is the uncertainty
in the Occupy Market
now that is quite interesting and we're
seeing a different
material change actually from decision
making for occupiers many have deferred
because they're uncertain about the
workplace they're uncertain about the
use of the building
but what is materializing is is that
that use is not necessarily transforming
into reduced floor space
and actually from our research at the
moment
the city of London
demand for office space is now above the
pre-pandemic position
ESG is playing a very important part as
well in that decision-making process
so a lot of companies are now realizing
that actually owning their own Office
Buildings
has given them a considerable headache
in terms of flexibility in design
and also a longer term position in terms
of
adding and requiring to add value
Capital value into the into the
investment so a lot of companies that
own buildings are now actually looking
towards leasing buildings rather than
owning them
another change that we're starting to
see in the market
of course that supports investment
property very well
thank you Nigel councilor Omarosa
thank you
um I just want to uh
use this question to draw together a
couple of uh tonight's threads
it was interesting to hear Emily
talk about the investment in solar
panels on one of the Cisco roofs and
that that was considered to be
increasing the value of that property so
clearly our esteemed experts at cifco
see which way the wind is blowing and my
question is would you be interested in
liaising with the uh
the director for corporate resources and
the treasury management
team to advise on
investing in the future and
divesting from fossil fuels
thank you I'm always happy to liaise
with my colleagues in
um in in the council so yes absolutely
uh councilor eberne
very much chair um two quick questions
if I may
um at 12 13
um you talk about the um assets that
have been looked at and reviewed and so
on is there any kind of expectation of
um future sales of those and purchases
of
um of new
um
properties I mean and with any
particular time frame or was that
something that is just ongoing and then
secondly at 17.3 and 17.4 refer to
energy performance certificates epcs and
I just would like to know if
it's ambiguous as to whether tenants are
paying for that or sick goes paying for
that and I just wondered what the cost
whether there had been any costs
um applied to that for zipco thank you
chair
um so announced your first question and
the management of any property portfolio
must on an ongoing basis consider
um whether a property should continue to
be held or or sold and civco doesn't
have any additional funds for further
investment so there are clearly no
further Acquisitions currently planned
um who would only look to acquire
properties if an asset was sold we have
no plans to sell any assets at this
point in time
but we will continue to review the
portfolio and
respond according to the the
opportunities that are presented to us
in terms of the reference to epcs and so
as a landlord we are
um legally required to make sure there
is an EPC in place when we let a
property and so in terms of the actual
certificates being undertaken
they the cost of that is born by by the
landlord I think what you're referring
to however is probably in relation to
the works that need to be undertaken and
there's actually a sort of Blended
approach to that in in most situations
the tenants have the responsibilities in
relation to repairing and maintaining
their properties
and as such would probably carry the
responsibility for any upgrades that
they they seek to do however in some
situations
um we will have
um the opportunity to make some
improvements so where we have vacant
Properties or where we're responsible
for common parts so we can look at
making some changes in in those
instances and the other thing that we've
talked about as a board is actually
um talking to tenants as well so perhaps
if they come forward with some info
want to make we could actually say to
them that's really interesting but have
you also thought about business and this
and having some conversations help
encourage them take some further Steps
From A sustainability perspective as
well so so the answer really is that
that responsibility sits with both the
landlord and tenant depending on the
individual
um
lease terms and contract terms but as a
board we're very supportive to see more
sustainability measures and being
brought forward through the the
portfolio of assets
yeah
um so just to confirm there isn't
actually a cost in the budget for zipco
for EPC work at the moment and King
and so this Capital Works budget which
does include
um some EPC works most
um the largest Quantum of which is uh in
relation to um
the new solar panels that are being put
on on the roof of one of our properties
uh we're also undertaking some Works to
the common parts of one of our buildings
that will also benefit the EPC ratings
and in fact even the other properties
and that we have refurbished and brought
forward
within that Capital list they all had
um Works done that would result in
improved EPC so
um the budget is included within those
Capital Works Figures it's not set aside
as a separate amount but we do also have
other budgets and for repairs that
potentially we could look at
um prefer the works as we move forward
councilor Norris
thank you Mr chairman uh page 85
financial performance and acquisition
progress
there are two columns one for by about
and one from mid Suffolk
and at the head of the columns it shows
Revenue impact
now for baber it shows interest paid of
723 000
under mid sofa cover it shows interest
paid of 1.32 million
why such a big difference
consequently the net total revenue is
around six hundred thousand pounds less
for Miss Suffolk
uh is it to do with the makeup of the
borrowings and the terms on them
thank you
and so again that um question I'm going
to refer to Catherine Steele
um the 151 officer
foreign
thank you councilor um and yes I think
you've actually answered your own
question because you said was it due to
the makeup of the different borrowings
so yes it is so if you actually look at
the table in 12.2 which is on page 86 of
of the pack then it shows there the
difference in borrowing for sifco came
into being mid-suffolk had a larger
short-term borrowing than baber so they
have had to take more long-term
borrowing which is a higher a higher
cost baber is still taking more
advantage of being able to take
advantage of more at the short term
rates so it is that difference in in the
borrowing strategies between the two
councils
Council wall boys
thank you chair
um
this question wrongly to begin with
um first of all in terms of
book gloss of this I I didn't think it
was in the region of 10 million pounds I
I think I've revised that
higher tomorrow in the region of 20
million bearing in mind that we got the
last set
loss of 15.3 million plus the associated
costs of purchasing the properties which
we
we assume as a loss I I didn't you could
correctly on that with that I would
if you'd like to do that first there
there we go yeah 13 that's fine so the
the total losses to data in the order of
12.8 million and that loss is made up of
um the cost of acquisition and the
reduction in value of the portfolio so
that is roughly four and a half million
pounds in terms of the cost of
acquisition and just over 7 million for
a reduction in value there is also an
element of bad debt that's been written
off that's also included within that and
figure but that was the roughly 300 000
pounds that was mentioned earlier
Council wall boys yes
that's good and you know I welcome to
see that we actually started making um
capital investment in the property and
improving it I'm assuming that might
include change of use as well
um
and that we've adopted a sustainability
policy but my big query if you like is
about the risk management which is um
oh dear page 91 which seems to be
um
very short
you know I'd like
I would like to say if you like a risk
management perhaps looking at the values
how low can the value of the property go
to how high there's a margin of error
here in looking into the future
um and we can deal with probabilities at
this age but we need to know
in this balancing of income and
investment and asset value how wide
these margins are
and so we do have very robust approach
to risk in terms of the management of um
sifco so the summary within the report
is a very
um very small summary related to the
council's risks in terms of investment
but we do look at risk very carefully
um with the board of sifco and and the
chairs of the holding company as well so
please be reassured that we do have
quite a comprehensive risk register and
I'd be more than happy to share with
that with you
outside of this meeting and in terms of
the I suppose sensitivity in relation to
where values are likely to go again that
is always a challenge to be able to
forecast where values are likely to be
because there are lots of circumstances
that can occur that can can impact on
that including a pandemic for instance
and I do take your point in terms of
presenting to council
um a bit more information in that in
that space and I'd be more than happy to
have a look at that for next year's
business plan proposals
right that looks like we've come to the
end oh no
councilor mayor
if I may
sift Coast performance when measured
against industry standards
you come on on that list
so I think it depends on which standards
that that you really want to look at but
there are some
um
indices within the report particularly
around rent collection which show that
civco has
repeatedly performed better than other
similar or other funds in terms of rent
collection so we've been looking at rent
collection in excess of 95
a quarter on quarter throughout the
whole pandemic and whilst it may have
taken a bit more time to get to that
then we ordinarily would have seen our
end results are really showing that
we've had really strong and robust rent
collection across the um the last 18
months or so and interestingly this week
probably our largest debtor
actually cleared their debt so uh
um our debt rated has reduced from the
amount that's reported in in the report
so it's gone down for them from around
about 170 000 pounds
last week down to closer to about 100
105 000 pounds so we've seen some
significant improvements
um in in recent days even in terms of
our rent collection figures
uh thank you chair apologies it was
actually just a request that before we
move into debate could I suggest we have
a a journal for a small Comfort break
because I think we've been with two and
a half hours or thereabouts into the
meeting and we've still got quite a lot
to get through
please go ahead
mentioned the capital values uh we are
or you're expecting them to recover
within 10 years
um can you tell us what the impact on
Revenue in the short term will be when
that happens
sorry so in terms of Revenue in the
short term so in the short term our
revenue is um is holding up so there is
very limited impact on Revenue in the
short term and over the longer term as
values improve we will continue to grow
both the revenue and the capital value
of the portfolio and so we'll see
um improved performance both in terms of
that continual Revenue stream that
accounts
has seen since sifco's Inception but
will also start to see those Capital
values come through as well
right I think we have come to the end of
questions and I did say right at the
beginning that around this time we would
take a break so
um we will will do so and we'll take a
10 minute break it is now 7 55 uh could
we all be back here at 805 please thank
you
right everyone's feeling a little bit
more comfortable after that short break
uh I think we're at the point now where
we're going to move to the debate
um so it's three minutes each only one
go each
um who would like to start
councilor Matheson
thank you chair well it's it's quite
well known that I I never liked the
principle of cifco at all and I just
like to
um wonder I went and looked to see what
was we're actually going to vote on and
um
having noted the accounts we're going to
approve or otherwise the the business
plan and I just wondered whether this is
a question really whether in considering
the
um business plan the board had actually
considered flogging the whole lot for
the 12 million pound loss and um and
actually putting it into housing in our
own District
um when I'm baby I suppose half each and
um and whether that might not recover
the capital loss is a lot quicker
actually
um and on that basis I'm not going to be
able to support the um all right the
motion
thank you councilor Mathison
right
councilor Richardson
thank you chair I wasn't planning on on
making a contribution to the debate but
I would just say in response to what
about councilor mathison's just said
very briefly I don't potentially well
particularly see the value in selling
off part of the portfolio to offset the
loss given that the loss itself will
only be materialized if and when we sell
aspects of the portfolio so I think that
view is a little bit contradictory and
unsurprisingly I'll be uh voting in
favor of the recommendations in the
report thank you chair
chairman thank you
um
I'd think a vote's support really and
thanks uh councilor Gould well done
really good report very very detailed
and a heck of a lot of work that's gone
into it and also from Emily and the rest
of the team
um the work you put into this is
appreciated and actually was good
reading I wonder what the world would be
like and this report be like if this
pandemic hadn't occurred
that is a critical factor to this as
well like all Investments they go up
they go down this is this point in time
and I've got great confidence in the
team that's behind it that the future is
bright the Investments are bright and
actually next year when we have the
report it'd be a different story thank
you
foreign
this
report
uh you know basically I've just always
felt that the risk for relatively small
council is too much
sure enough if property values do
recover and some types of property have
always recovered perhaps housing
although I've done courage when it's
gone down quite dramatically 25 or more
and when I looked at I must admit I tend
to look at the CCNA figures of course in
another world we have substantial money
in there you look to their property
portfolio after the uh the crash in 2008
it went down a long way for a long time
so it's an issue of risk obviously
diversifying the property benefits that
but the larger companies the
shareholders of this world and whatever
are diversify it across a number of
economies
um so if they're unfortunate enough to
be in Tokyo a few years ago 20 years ago
they're still below the water if they're
fortunate enough to be in North America
they're doing well
clearly we're not we're in a single
country the UK although we might be in a
number of different cities so
that's the point my I feel the risk
is too high for a small Council and
therefore I won't support
thank you Mr chairman
um it's well known that on this side of
the council that we hold a principled
objection to sifco we don't think that's
what a council should be doing borrowing
money from the public works loan board
and then investing it
and the government agrees with that
because it stopped uh councils from
doing that
does that mean that if cifco goes wrong
and it makes substantial losses that we
will be jumping up and down and
celebrating and saying we told you so
absolutely not
the people of mid-suffolk need sifco to
succeed
even
we on this side want it to succeed
though we don't think the principle of
it is right
I agree with councilor Humphreys that
this has been a very difficult year of
trading and maybe in this year of years
this report represents a good result or
perhaps the best we could expect
but the whole Foundation of sifco is
predicated on this idea of borrowing
money at low interest rates
investing it and then the balance of the
return there being a difference between
the two enough to give us some profit
and now we're in a situation where low
interest rates are in no way guaranteed
and we don't have everything locked in
to long-term low interest rates so I
think again the the foundation of this
concept is still shaky
and we on this side would say it's not a
good idea I think perhaps you guys on
that side have said you think it is a
good idea to my mind the jury is still
out
the councilor Gould talks of net income
incomes only net income if you disregard
the capital losses
and I don't find it easy to do that
so um yes I'm happy to note the report
but I can't approve the business plan so
I'll be voting against this proposal
thank you
thank you councilor councilor mayor
Saint councilor Mellon myself and many
others in this room were not here
We inherited zip code
now I'm a Believer in zip code I believe
it contributes
um but to hear people saying they will
not vote for a business plan I haven't
heard any criticisms of the business
plan
councilor Mellon was absolutely right
Suffolk needs sifco to succeed and to
hear people abrogating their
responsibilities by refusing to vote for
a business plan I find
really disappointing
we here benefit from a fantastic group
of people
they have performed ahead of every
Benchmark they're measured against
they have
turned what could have been a disastrous
year into
a better than expected year and I think
in the future they will deliver they
deserve our support
I've heard no suggestions from the other
side of the house about how
business plan should be amended
your members of your Wards need this to
succeed we need you to get on board so
sustainability
sifco is struggling with how do you
measure sustainability
they've gone for the EPC
um evaluations is that right
how much should we be investing in solar
panels on buildings
it won't surprise you to know that sifco
are investing in sustainability because
it makes economic sense to do so
people are trading up their buildings
and they only want to move into a better
building more sustainable how much
should we be investing should we be
investing more than the revenue that
we're going to get back this is the sort
of conversation we should have
I fully accept that you don't like zip
code I didn't get a vote on cifco I do
the sithco but we've got to move on we
have a business plan that we need to
evaluate
so that we can show that we fully
support the people that we have employed
to deliver sithco
they're not elected they are employed by
us to deliver and we've got to give them
Direction
so when I hear people saying I won't
vote for the business plan without
putting forward
suggestions how it can be approved I
find that abrogating responsibility
you're letting your War members down and
so must succeed we've got to make it
succeed so please get on board
I will be voting for the business plan
in front of us today thank you
[Applause]
Council Australia
thank you I wasn't going to speak on
this item until councilor mayor spoke
and actually I think I promised one of
the directors I wouldn't be speaking on
it but I I was around to have that vote
and yes there's a huge inherent danger
to
our citizens and the people we represent
if sifco doesn't succeed
but
I was here for that vote
and I voted for a different investment
model and all the ideas of how to do
that
were debated then
and we haven't used this opportunity to
re-rehearse what would have happened
if this side of the house had have
prevailed
all I can say is we would not be looking
at any losses at all we would be looking
at spectacular gains
so we've not taken that that opportunity
to beat you over the head with we won't
but please forgive us if we don't back a
plan that we didn't back from the
Inception thank you chair
thank you chairman
um councilor mayor's speech is a
difficult act to follow but I do want to
say that I'm happy to put on record that
I have real confidence in the board and
advisors of Cisco I believe they have an
excellent ongoing business plan and I
fully support and endorse it
I've always regarded sifco as the proper
and well Justified long-term investment
by our two councils to deliver long-term
dependable and growing income stream for
our two councils in addition I am
confident in the generation of capital
gains and the preservation of our
investment in real inflation-proof terms
in the longer run so no pressure guys
there nothing we've experienced with
cefco since its Inception including the
unique covid-19 pandemic makes me waver
from that viewpoint
those that speak against sifco and yes
we liquidate the portfolio never offer
any plausible alternatives to The
crucial income stream that sithco
generates now and will continue to
generate far into the future
but I suppose it's a fact of life that
opposition does come without that
responsibility
member for finance I don't have that
luxury but I'm clearing my mind I am
totally at ease with our Cisco
investment
are some of the councils have taken the
property investment concept far too far
and in doing so generated strong
criticism regarding the whole concept
but in the case of both baber and with
Suffolk I believe that criticism is
totally unjustified
so I will be voting in favor of this
business plan thank you Jeff thank you
counselor so um it is a very shortly
going to be 8 30 and the guillotine will
fall so I'd like a proposal to extend
and a second please so
thank you Council Richardson councilor
Lavigne so can we do by a show of hands
please to extend the gluteene
that's carried thank you very much so uh
thank you chair
I didn't expect to speak either
um but I can now say things that I could
not say overview of scrutiny because
um we were looking at just certain
aspects of the business plan
um and we were non-political in that
debate
but I'm not quite so constrained now but
I do want to respond to councilor mayor
because he challenges us to to say
what's missing from the plan and I would
like to I would like to explain one
thing that I think is missing
and it's the same as I asked for last
year and I probably asked for the year
before and that is that within the
business plan there should be what you
could call a phased exit strategy or a
sales strategy or whatever
so that at the right time units are sold
I've had this discussion uh uh with with
offices and what I've what I've
understood is
but yeah when the time is right we will
sell a unit and then we will reinvest
now what I would what I would ask for is
that that is in the business plan and it
is in the business plan that we will
reinvest and we will reinvest in house
building homes for our residents because
they will have income they'll have homes
they'll be good homes and that's that is
that is a benefit to the district rather
than continue continuing paying back all
these loans thank you
thank you councilor Willem
uh Council councilor custom
thank you Mr chairman
um I just want to unpack this idea of
cashing in this investment and building
houses or are we buying houses
um do you realize how many houses that
would be and who who's Ward would you
want them to go in it it would be a
ridiculous amount of houses so it would
take so long to make that sustainable it
would be almost impossible the um also
we've talked about how we had officers
that need a market and we they they were
valued us none of these investments in
offices are anything like need a market
need a market had its Heyday in the
1950s and it was unsuitable these
Investments are far more like Endeavor
house there will always be companies
that want to move to Modern buildings
and this type of thing we're not buying
any needed Market offices that are
falling apart and the class has fallen
off the walls the um the other thing is
as a landlord to them
we got the opportunity to build
um to put solar panels on the roof to
we've discussed how a business has been
allowed to run after debt when it
couldn't pay the rent that we we have
the ability to make these Investments so
much better for the businesses in it
than maybe a private landlord would I
fully support this I think this is a
great thing for the council and in 40 40
years time I think people will be
looking at this as one of the great
things that this council did when
everything's paid off and they've just
got this income from this uh this
investment stream that we've had the
guts to actually go into and and do so
um I will be supporting this I'm all for
it and um
I'll be voting for it tonight
thank you councilor
councilor and Morrison
thank you Jeff I'm loving all this uh
enthusiasm for uh investing in
Sustainable Building Technology
um will we be applying that logic to
housing stock and future housing
um
developments in the in the
in the area okay
I I you know is that a question to you
no no Mr chairman no counselor you've
had your say and uh thank you councilor
omarosan uh right well I'd like to have
a little say
um
you know
I I was here when we decided to do cifco
and and I I could understand the logic
and the imperative that drove it and
effectively I see the proof is in the in
the eating of the pudding because Cisco
has delivered income streams to our
Council and if you care to study the
business plan closely you will see that
it's going to deliver further income
streams over the coming years
and and this is against the background
as you all well know where central
government has severely constrained
funding to to local councils while his
vote is zero now that's one time we were
and I think
um we have in cifco a very responsible
landlord a very well-run company
um which is why I think that they're
able to have outperformed the industry
in terms of rent collection and in in
terms of uh the the work that they're
doing to guard the value of the
portfolio going forward and I would
suggest and I'm sure Emily could correct
me if I wrong but with a with a wart of
over eight years I think that's pretty
darn good in terms of comparisons with
the industry so
from my perspective as a district
councilor
um I think this is a very good thing and
it provides us with income that allows
us to continue to invest in our
Frontline services and and there's never
been more of a demand for that than
there is today and so with that I would
like to call on Council of Guru to see
if he wishes to add anything further
thank you Mr chairman that very little I
think one of the consequences of um uh
questions passing appropriately uh
directly to uh to Emily and then uh on
to the advices I didn't get the
opportunity uh as is the custom in this
Council
um to thank the questionnaire for their
for their questions uh which I would
like uh to to to do now and and comment
on the questions themselves what one
thing that I think is noticeably
different this time is that the
questions are less
trade show a growing understanding about
the nature of the cifco of the sifco
business uh and whilst I unders up to a
point I understand that uh that side of
the chamber is never going to be or may
never be a Living Hope convinced about
this kind of activity at least there is
evidence in my mind of of a grain
understanding through the
appropriateness of the questions being
being asked having that was up to the
point of the the debate when actually
some of those kind of older attitudes
reveal themselves uh
this is not a question about we do this
or we build houses actually we're doing
both I mean over the next four years red
stuff is going to build some 150
affordable homes
uh we don't we do doing that as well as
uh the cifco Investments uh I can't
imagine the greater Folly than selling
off
um our our assets uh just because at the
moment they are a a low value that's the
time not to sell them uh we hang on to
them we are yes
um
uh expressing confidence in long-term uh
Rising Capital uh value of our assets
and history is behind us uh in that
uh opiate uh as Council Phil points out
it's uh the the period of growth might
be quite a long one but the point here
with cefco is that we are not reliant on
that Capital Growth this is about income
generation through uh receipt of uh
rents uh thank you to councilor
Humphries for his his uh kind words and
his observation about uh giving that our
performance has been this successful uh
in a time of covid
um how much better might it be have been
uh in a normal time and and as being
said our performance against the
industry uh at large has been good which
which actually uh counters some of the
uh anti-municipal uh comments that you
often think well how can a council
possibly be doing this work uh wisely or
well well this council is doing it why
is he and well uh because we have a
great team uh as you as as you know uh
both both in terms of Emily but also in
terms of our external advisors
so I would like to at your invitation
leave it leave it there uh uh and uh
happy to propose and look forward to a
positive vote on this item
thank you chair that vote is now um
turning blue so if counselors could
place their vote thank you
Council of War boys are you okay to vote
thank you chair that is 17 votes for the
recommendations and 11 against
it
I'd like to invite accounts
thank you very much chair I am delighted
to introduce to the Council of
mid-suffolk's first well-being strategy
and to move the recommendations in the
report by way of background members will
be aware that this strategy was
conceived before the pandemic and has
been in development for well over a year
we held an all-member Workshop in August
last year to discuss our priorities
followed by an additional Workshop in
May to consider how the one million
pound well-being funding can help
deliver the help deliver them with a
further briefing earlier this month
in effect therefore this strategy sets
out our priorities and our objectives
for well-being over the next six years
if approved it will be followed by a
more detailed delivery plan that sets
out how we achieve those priorities and
objectives and as mentioned will be
supported by the one million pound
well-being funding that the council
agreed back in February
this is important as understanding our
well-being priorities will enable us to
make the most effective use of our
simply put our well-being vision is that
the residents of mid-suffolk will have
the best possible conditions for good
well-being and have lives that are
healthy happy and rewarding
we must recognize of course that the
covid-19 pandemic has had a profound
impact on our communities and we want to
be explicitly clear that we want this
strategy to play a central role in
helping support our residents through
the aftermath of this immensely
challenging period
to that end we have identified three
overarching long-term outcomes which are
for families to lead active healthy safe
and independent lives and manage their
own health and well-being
for communities to have sustainable and
inclusive places and spaces which
maximize health and wellbeing
opportunities and benefits and to
achieve a reduction in health
inequalities
as this strategy spans the period to
2027 our long-term outcomes are
supported by a set of shorter term
outcomes that will focus on the next two
years and which are accompanied by more
detailed objectives which are set out in
the strategy and in turn will be
delivered in Partnership both with both
internal and external stakeholders
it is I must point out well recognized
at the broader determinants of
well-being are particularly important
ensuring in ensuring a healthy and happy
population and there are also these are
also the types of issues of well-being
issues over which councils have some
control and influence for example
through stimulating our local economy
managing our environment developing and
maintaining uh developing and managing
our homes or by providing Leisure
facilities to our residents
this strategy therefore does not aim and
I would like to stress this point does
not aim to duplicate the well-being
aspects contained already within our
economy housing environmental Community
strategies
however these other strategies will be
reviewed to ensure that well-being
outcomes are being optimized and
performance in relation to those aspects
will be included when we are reporting
on our performance in respect to
well-being
in particular the strategy cites the 10
measures of national well-being
developed by the office of national
statistics which organizes nationally
surveyed and gathered data into
different areas of life affecting
well-being we've chosen to adopt these
10 areas with a focus on personal
well-being relationships Health the
communities where we live and what we do
with our time the remaining five will
then be incorporated into the other
strategies that I mentioned and
supporting this we have extensive data
contained at the end of the strategy
which help to underpin our areas of
focus
while developing the strategy however we
haven't Stood Still and have delivered a
number of projects and supported many of
our communities these include the active
schools and active wellbeing programs
chill chat and play and the outdoor
explore and family cooking days all of
which have already had a profoundly
positive impact for our residents
in developing this strategy we have also
engaged broadly with our two clinical
commissioning groups Suffolk County
Council and Key Community stakeholders
this is important because we must
identify clearly the role of a district
council and Not Duplicate the work of
other statutory functions such as public
health instead we have the opportunity
to look at health and well-being in a
much broader sense and to enhance the
role that we play in supporting our
residents and our communities
um I am as you can probably tell
exceptionally proud of both this
strategy and the broader purpose behind
it and so in closing I would like to
thank the officers involved to produce
this document in the shadow of the worst
Global Health crisis in a century is
nothing short of heroic in particular
I'd like to commend the efforts of the
following people to whom I am especially
grateful namely Zoe banthorpe Tom Barker
David Clark Simon Lanning Vicki Mosley
Kathy Nixon who we have here and Aruna
Sharma balls I must also recognize the
work contributed by councilor flapman as
Cabinet member for communities who led
down this strategy before my portfolio
was created and councilor Morley who as
leader has been an enthusiastic
supporter of the well-being agenda and
so finally I commend these strategy as a
means of promoting the health and
well-being of our residents and ensuring
that the resources allocated and
targeted intelligently to those that
need the most I'm very pleased therefore
to propose the recommendations in this
report and would like to invite Council
flattman to Second them thank you chair
thank you councilor Richardson
uh it's my pleasure to Second this
um strategy and I can only reiterate
everything councilor Richardson has said
and especially to all the officers who
worked on this while we had covered and
their day job was answering telephone
calls helping our residents and
literally dealing with grants coming
flying through the window every other
minute so thank you guys
usual counselors
um can ask as many questions questions
as they wish but again please stick to
the subject under discussion and
with a question rather than a huge long
Preamble the floor is open to questions
councilor Mansell
uh thank you chair I too I I welcome uh
well-being strategy and I think as
others have already said a lot of work's
been gone into it
um I am looking in particular at
paragraph 411 where we have some
long-term outcomes that we are focusing
on which I think are all highly
commendable but I would just like to
know how we're going to measure against
those outcomes thank you
thank you councilor councilor Richardson
apologies check would you just give me
one minute while I find that particular
aspect sure
councilor Mansell what page are you
referring to uh
sorry apologies Chair for My benefit I
haven't got the full pack open I've only
got the actual strategy could councilor
Mansell please just show me oh I think
I've actually got it three four four
long-term outcomes
4.11
foreign
[Music]
yes okay so apologies I'm with you know
that is that has thrown me a little bit
um yeah so I'd imagine once we as I
mentioned in my introduction once we
have
um the more dedicated delivery plan in
place provided we agree what those uh
what those long-term outcomes will be
that will provide the
um mechanism by which we can Benchmark
the actual
um specific deliverables we want to see
because until we've got that plan in
place until we can do that benchmarking
we won't know how we can measure them
but I would certainly expect to see that
level of detail come forward as part of
the delivery plan but if there's a
follow-up question based on that I'll
certainly try my best to answer it well
sorry I I um I under I think I
understand where you're coming from it's
going to be in a future piece of work I
think is what you basically said so
presumably uh we also need to know uh
where we are now I we measure against
those sort of outcomes so that we know
you know because we've got like families
to lead active healthy well-being a safe
independent lives
um we obviously want that to be more
families than now
so we also need to know where we are now
so we need to sort of Baseline as well
as some sort of benchmarking I'm
presuming but that I presume your your
answer is that will come in a future
piece of work
thank you uh for that question
councilman and I think partially so in
terms of that specific question around
the baselining I think that's a very
good point and what there has been uh
what has been done is extensive analysis
of the data
um that sits within the strategy which
is
um located at the bottom well I don't
think perhaps this strategy is setting
out is exactly that analysis but I'm
very confident that that has taken place
because I've seen
um some other versions of of other
documentations that contains exactly
that analysis of our performance I think
the reason it's not included in this
strategy or this document is the
strategy is deliberately intended to be
that high level prioritization and
deciding of of particular outcomes and
objectives but I can certainly outside
of this meeting we can provide some of
that analysis that forms part of the
baselining but yes in answer to the
other part of the question if it is if I
can put it more simply yes we'll come
forward in a future piece of work to
give you some of that specific
benchmarking
thank you Council councilor e Byrne
we chair I'll try to make my quest
um I'm I'm sure that you're able to
answer this though but the a lot of the
aspects within this strategy
um in terms of the work that um what
goes on at mid-suffolk will actually
relate to planning and in terms of how
shape
um our place shaping and planning
applications and open spaces and so on
so
is it possible that we will be able to
use this strategy or the um delivery
plan from it in with regards to planning
policy and also at planning committee
thank you very much thank you
uh thank you accountable for that
question it's a very good one I will try
my best to answer it but but I will
leave it to whatever we don't actually
have any planning Offices here who I'd
need to to defer to my understanding and
sort of Suspicion is that no we couldn't
reference it as an adopted planning
policy document within the context of a
planning committee but one of the things
I would say is that I know uh the
councilor burn and Tom Barkley assistant
director
um have been having conversations
already about how we can incorporate
aspects of this both into the joint
local plan itself and whether there's a
substantive parts of that document that
will give strength to the to the
outcomes and objectives within this
document but also in future there is I
think nothing stopping the council
considering a a supplementary planning
document that reinforces exactly what's
in this but my suspicion is and again
please don't take this as given this is
just my interpretation and I'd need
clarification from planning offices is
that this would not be given substantive
weight in a planning determination if
that makes sense
thank you councilor uh councilor geek
thank you chair
um I'm sorry this is going to involve a
bit of a preamble but it will only be a
minute and a half I promise
one of the things necessary to increase
well-being is to give the guarantee of a
safety net for the risk of losing your
income a safety net that can catch
people without shame and that removes
the fear of extreme poverty and
destitution and since 1945 of course the
UK has to a greater or lesser extent had
a welfare safety net so that its
population can afford to take risks
afford to be enterprising or flexible in
their careers and the current iteration
of that safe genetics is Universal
Credit
the government is proposing to cut 20
pounds a week from Universal Credit a
huge cut in percentage terms would they
would you consider lobbying Parliament
to abandon or mitigate as I gather is
being planned at the moment the cut in
Universal Credit given that this is
going to affect people in work as much
as those out of work
thank you for that question Council I
appreciate my portfolio is still
evolving but I do consider that to be
ever so slightly outside of my remit
thank you
thank you chair
um I welcome the strategy and I welcome
the opportunity to give local support
within the delivery plan
um I'm hoping that local Ward members
will have an opportunity to help shape
the delivery plan and to work with local
local groups to help to deliver the
outcomes in our Awards
um
that wasn't a question well so the
question is will we be given the
opportunity to work with
um will the local board members be given
the opportunity to work with others for
the delivery in our Awards a couple of
other questions I believe that we in
midst it's mid-suffolk may be in a
better position financially than our
colleagues in baber to deliver outcomes
from this strategy
um will the fact that we are in a better
position financially than them hold us
back
um and the third is not a question
which is all right I'll turn it into a
question then
can you ten seconds
can you tell me where Crawford school
and Freeman School are in Stone Market
please
is that not
they're in store Upland councilor
once you'd stay up and one's in holy
yeah okay
there were questions
Council Richardson I my apologies I have
counselor William has so distracted me
that I
just go ahead thank you thank you Chad
um so base so if I can just take each of
those questions in order in terms of the
uh delivery plan itself so I think just
important to highlight that the content
of that which is it's not well it's not
finalized yet by any means but we have
been basing it based we've been
producing it based on what's both in the
strategy but also been informed by the
well-being or the outcomes of the
well-being Workshop that was held back
in in May which obviously was a
cross-party uh all member Workshop so
that any any ideas and suggestions that
were fed in
um at that Workshop will then be
reflected we hope in the delivery plan
but absolutely of course we can we can
arrange a separate briefing because just
in terms of just to give absolute
Clarity I don't think the expectation is
at the delivery plan itself would come
back to full Council I think the
recommendations in the report uh make
clear that that's a delegated
responsibility for cabinet and offices
so as part of that process I'd be more
than happy to arrange a separate all
member Workshop to go or briefly through
that and just specifically again
absolutely of course we'll work in
consultation with local Ward members
wherever it's convenient for us to do so
um secondly on the question of Finance
I've already you know referenced on
several occasions the one million
funding
um that we're providing as part of the
well-being agenda which again will come
in in very close
um sort of connection with the uh with
the delivery plan uh therefore the
question will baber and their respective
financial position hold us back I would
just say absolutely emphatically no we
will fund whatever we need to fund as
part of this agenda
um and I hope I speak on behalf of my
colleagues on this side of the chamber
when I say that
um and asked me the third question I
think that was largely rhetorical and
that you've answered it so actual add
nothing more thank you chair thank you
councilor Richardson councilor Emma
Rosen
teacher
thing that councilor Richardson
um did not acknowledge the link between
economics and well-being
um
in his role
and uh I guess what is the question
would the council recognize that
GDP
isn't necessarily A good measure of
well-being
that was just a side note to move to my
actual question
if we zoom out
and uh look at other emerging factors
that are affecting well-being
in our societies
what what is coming to light is the
proliferation of social media usage
by
many demographics
um counselor yes what is your question
I'll get to that can you actually get to
it okay
you put me off the track
awful
um
social media has its benefits but what's
emerging is the harms and detrimental
effects it can have on certain
demographics in society namely young
teenagers
um in terms of mental health uh teenage
suicide so
the question is
in the future or going forward could we
recognize this can we put it on our
radar as an issue
I'm thinking about acknowledging it as a
as some kind of emergency because these
Technologies are only expanding
exponentially in terms of their
capabilities
um
so can it be acknowledged that this is
an issue that we might want to keep an
eye on and what can they cancel
contribute to this debate
thank you very much for that question if
I can just turn to the first part of of
your remarks just to clarify something
that
the economy does play an enormous the
local column plays an enormously
significant part of this strategy It's
contained within there it's part of the
the 10 indicators that we've pulled out
and included in this and we've made
explicitly I've made it explicitly clear
at the beginning of my introduction that
we will be reflecting our well-being
outcomes and our well-being priorities
Within
economy strategy I also make clear that
there's a very important distinction
between the role we can play as a
district council and that therefore the
implementation or otherwise of aspects
of the broader welfare state is not
within my remit and I think we should be
very clear in defining the scope of what
it is we're trying to achieve but with
that in mind I absolutely agree with
with the ask with them the the gist of
accounts for Morrison's question one of
the aspects that I think is really
significant and which will be reflected
in
um part of the delivery plan will be the
youth social prescribing program that we
are looking to introduce that will
involve working very closely with GP
practices and schools to develop
appropriate packages of support and care
for children who are experiencing
exactly that type of Mental Health
crisis or or otherwise suffering from
anxiety depression Etc so I'll
absolutely consider that very carefully
going forward and I'm sure we'll see
aspects of exactly that kind of digital
awareness included in some of the
schemes that we have going forward thank
you chair
thank you councilor uh
counselor War boys
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Richardson I think you've brought
forward a well-being strategy which has
got some very high ideals and will no
doubt benefit the community in many
different ways as well it's suffer you
have a budget of one million pounds plus
whatever can be gained
from other sources
in view of delivering these high ideals
would you consider actually
exceeding that budget and coming forward
with a request for enough funds to
deliver the ideals rather than feel
constrained by your budget
thank you very much for that question
Council all boys I'm going to have to be
very careful what I say given that I'm
sat next to the cabinet member for
finance and in answer to your question I
will borrow one of his phrases and say
probably
thank you chair
um one of the strategies short to medium
term outcomes is that people will have
access to homes that are affordable and
well-built sustainable attractive and in
tune with their surroundings
currently our planning system makes it
extremely difficult to provide more
affordability better and more
Sustainable Building standards and more
attractive homes
what is that in the strategies
objectives that can achieve this or as I
suspect I think the housing crisis May
unfortunately be outside Council which
is some dream it too and I apologize if
that is so
thank you very much for that question
councilor geek
um so one of the things that I think
I've made clear in the remarks when I
first introduced this report is that
there are aspects of this strategy which
will Interlink with the other strategies
and policies that we have as a as a
council and I think that's why I made
clear to counselor eben's question that
this will not be a document that can be
as far as I understand it directly
referenced as a planning policy document
within the context of of the
consideration of development but one of
the things that we are looking to do in
conjunction with planning is look at how
exactly we can embed some of this more
specifically into the policies and the
documents that we do have whether that's
through the jlp whether that's through a
potential supplementary planning
document in the future
um this I I will just point out this
strategy sets out what we want to
achieve over the next uh six years to
2027 we there's plenty of work to to be
done after this point to then make sure
that we do deliver that but that will
have to come with time as I think I've
mentioned previously so what this is
doing this this objective setting
exercise if you like is saying this is
what we want to achieve and then we as
as the administration in conjunction
with our Ox is obviously we'll go in and
try and deliver that I hope that answers
that question thank you chair uh thank
you councilor Richardson and thank you
uh councilors for your comprehensive
questioning of of uh councilor
Richardson's presentation
um I'm very conscious that we're up
against the time limit so I'd like to
now move to uh debate and councilors
will have the usual three minutes to say
their say and which will be timed and
each of you will have one opportunity to
do so so I guess uh councilor e Bern
you'd want to kick off
thank you very much chair um I I will be
voting in favor of this um strategy
because I'm really pleased to see it
coming forward and I'd particularly like
to say that I think the process for
getting here was um very good I think
the member workshops were good I think
it was great to all get together and
actually listen to each other's ideas in
a non-confrontational
um location and actually listen and talk
to each other and so on and so I think
that was a very good approach and I
would welcome that for um you know it
might take a bit of time but I really
think it's a it's a it's a good approach
to do and something that we should be
doing more of
um I think the
um one of the things I have got a slight
concern about is the um you might not
have seen it yet Council Richardson but
the Thrive index came out today and
unfortunately mid-suffolk's rating has
dropped again and it's dropped every
year over the past three years and this
is an index for um lots of um well for
thriving to show thriving communities
and obviously part of that to do with
health and well-being
um and while at mid-suffix rating fell
from 2019 to 2020 and again to 21 other
councils have gone the other way and
they've increased their rating and moved
into the green let's say whereas we're
now steadily going into the red but I
was just wondering as well and this I
know it's not we're not doing questions
but I would hope that we can actually
look at the councils that are in the in
the green of that October they're doing
really well and actually see if they're
doing any particular ideas that we
should be borrowing and we should take
forward because if if they're doing
something they've been improving their
councils over the last few years then
let's just copy it
um but overall I'd like to say I will be
supporting this and I'm pleased to see
um this coming forward and I think the
council should do as much as we can
towards the health and well-being of all
our residents thank you chair
thank you councilor councilor Byrne
thank you chairman
was actually going
to come to councilor for Richardson Aid
in answering question uh from Council
Eben and councilor geek regarding the
relationship between planning and and
well-being
um uh I'm going to quote from an email
that I received from Tom Barker
just a few days ago pointing out that he
wasn't going to be at the council
meeting and this week
um so in that case
um I think I'm going to present to be
Tom and read a paragraph that says I was
heavily involved with developing the
well-being strategy when it fell within
my managerial responsibilities
since the organization changed changed
those by reorganizing my role I have
been less involved but it still remains
a subject very close to my heart and it
does have significant relevance to what
planning should be achieving in respect
of providing places that improve
well-being
um he goes on to quote from the strategy
and says our approach to planning and
the decisions taken by councilors all
have a significant impact on whether
these things will be achieved and our
jails and our jlp supports their
delivery
um
it is also important to a range of other
aims of the strategy but the above are
the most directly and immediately
obvious and the above are the quoted
sections that relate specifically to
planning in in the strategy
um Tom for those who
and this is more for the benefit of the
recording than anything else Tom is our
assistant director for
um uh for planning and sustainable
development and therefore I think his
views are very pertinent to what uh
councilor Eben and councilor geek were
asking and um of course he has my
support in this as well so whatever can
be done on the planning front to further
these aims we will of course try to do
thank you thank you councilor councilor
Emma Rosa
I'm interested in uh what councilor burn
just said about
um
Tom saying
the changes to his role had meant that
um that well-being was no longer part of
his remit and what those changes to the
role were and why they were um
made so I don't know who can drop that
question to right now but I just want to
raise that as a something for us to be
aware of
yeah chairman am I able to respond to
that question
[Music]
because because I think the question
actually refers to officer structures so
councilors may remember that we made a
change to the senior leadership team
earlier in the year in order to create
dedicated resource that the assistant
director level for health and well-being
and for communities so that meant a
shuffling round of responsibilities uh
so previously uh Mr Barker had a
responsibility for planning and for
communities and well-being given the
importance that I'm hearing all of you
place on this which is reassuring we
created an additional role of assistant
director specifically just for
communities in health and well-being
that's a shared role both across our two
districts Mid-South again baba but also
with our two ccg partners it's currently
vacant we haven't been able to appoint
to it thus far but we have been able to
secure some interim support who's
at the start of next month
thank you very much Arthur for rescuing
me there that's wonderful
um right
counselor geek
thank you chair um I'm really pleased
that councilor Richardson has these
aspirations to increase well-being
things like low incomes inequality
physical and mental health access to
sustainable transport access to care for
our elderly relatives and endicuts for
local government services all of these
things are absolutely crucial to
well-being and I will also be voting for
this laudable start to the process I
mean given that it is a
start it's really fantastic and I hope
that councilor Richardson and all
colleagues on the opposite side of the
chamber will Lobby the government who I
know listen to their local councilors
um
please could you Lobby them to it to or
you know can I encourage you to to
improve these factors under underlie
reduced well-being or at the very least
to ask somebody to stop making them
worse thank you
thank you I too will be voting to
support Council Richardson's motion and
I think I'd like to acknowledge now that
enormous amount of work communities team
are already doing to
support well-being within our community
um I think I just want to flag up a
little
concern though that I'm glad to hear
that councilor Richards has probably
won't compromise on his Ambitions for
this program
but from a briefing a week or so ago I'm
quite aware that communities is very
much driven by numbers in its response
and these numbers are growing
rapidly the pen the pandemic and its
effects are by no means over uh we're in
a very
uh
anxious economic situation with all
sorts of
uh external effects concerning our
communities so
I my
my feeling is that the budget will not
be sufficient it will the demands will
grow year on year and we must be
prepared to support it at Future Council
meters thank you
thank you councilor councilor Mellon
thank you chair yes I also welcome this
this strategy
and I look forward to having a positive
impact on on mid-suffolk I think we do
need to acknowledge um
the fact that I think how to Richardson
talked about this strategy being
interlinked with other policies of the
council I think sometimes we need to
acknowledge the fact that those two
things will be intention sometimes what
we want to achieve in terms of
well-being May Clash a little with some
of the other things that we have to do
some times constrained by what the
government asks us to do or perhaps
tells us to do but I I do more support
this this
um this strategy and an enormous amount
of work that's gone into it
you well for the future thank you
Morley
I can't really tell you how proud I am
of this well-being strategy that
councilor Richardson and before him
councilman flatland have been beavering
away at for
almost two years altogether
um together with the the communities
team and
um Tom Barker
and as it's become apparent during this
pandemic
Suffolk has a real aging population the
Aging demographic with a higher than
average incidence of people over 80. in
fact I believe that Norfolk can Suffolk
at the highest incidence of over 80s in
the country
dementia is a growing issue and there is
a need to support our growing population
to remain sorry
our aging population to remain
independent and in good health for as
long as possible in their own homes if
mental health issues have increased
during this pandemic for all age groups
and referrals
to Mental Health Services have risen
significantly
domestic abuse has also increased
isolation and loneliness has become an
even bigger issue
for not just for the old but also for
young as well and a quarter of the
population don't take regular exercise
so there's lots of things in this health
and well-being well-being strategy for
us to help influence
and our
strategy really is a partnership
approach
we can't possibly do all of this
ourselves
we work with Partners to deliver all
these outcomes as the chief exec has
just said
we have a new post of assistant director
for well-being
and this is jointly funded with our two
ccgs
but on top of that we also work very
closely with our colleagues in Suffolk
County Council to provide support and
also with the police and crime
commissioner
to help ameliorate anti-social behavior
and also ensure that we continue to
provide support to victims of ASB and
also to help and re-house families and
individuals where there are victims of
domestic abuse
so I have
I cannot express how proud I am of this
health and wellbeing strategy it is a
fantastic achievement in a relatively
short time space
and I'd like to thank everybody involved
in preparing it and I will definitely be
voting for this
thank you councilor councilor Willem
thank you chair
I also welcome the strategy and I'd like
to acknowledge the work of Vicki Mosley
and her colleagues not just in
developing the strategy but all the
other well-being work that's been going
on that many of us just don't see but
that we know that it goes on
as councilor Richardson has said
responsibility for developing the
delivery plans rests with the uh the
administration
but are just a plea in doing that don't
ignore this half of the council we are
50 of the council and we feel just as
passionately as anyone else about the
well-being of our residents
thank you councilor
um right I think that
thank you for that uh right
um well it is um quite heartwarming to
see that we we have a strategy that
um has been I think long overdue coming
to the fore and and being supported so
why be supported
um and I'd just like to thank everybody
that was involved in developing the
strategy for the great work that they've
done and and I honestly on a sort of
ground level basis we shouldn't ignore
that while that's been going on there's
been a lot of fantastic work going on on
the ground to support our citizens uh
through this very difficult time and I
would like to applaud the officers and
indeed the ward members that have
involved been involved in helping our
citizens through some of the
difficulties that they've had
um so without further Ado councilor
Richardson do you wish to add any more
before we moved over thank you chair
yesterday it's just a few final comments
um I've listened to the debate and I'd
like to thank all members who've made a
contribution
um and just to have a few sort of
General reflections
uh particularly interesting to see what
councilor Eben referenced in terms of
the Thrive index I haven't seen that
data it's published today but I do think
it reinforces precisely the need for
this strategy and the value of the work
that we can deliver as a result
um I absolutely concur with the comments
that Tom Barker made delivered in the
medium of councilor burn
um would also just take the
opportunities to reiterate my thanks for
here to him for his work on this
strategy I will certainly take on board
Council willem's point about engagement
and I'll I'll take that upon myself to
have a discussion with officers to how
he might best facilitate that in the
coming weeks
um
castle castle War boys also makes a good
point about resource and of course I
want us to do everything we can to
support our residents both directly and
with Partners as councilor morally quite
rightly emphasized in her contribution
um and I think that's what I would just
want to kind of reiterate in closing
this debate which is that this is very
much about defining what we can do as a
district council it's not within our our
statutory obligations it's very much
something we can elect to do ourselves I
think there's absolutely the need to do
that we do have the run the funding the
resource the capability to deliver and I
think we absolutely should so this
strategy and the delivery plan that will
support it in my view will genuinely
have a real meaningful and tangible
benefit to our residents and to our
communities and so I sincerely hope
dare I say it maybe I'm getting my hopes
up a little bit too much that will get
unanimous support for this strategy
thank you chair
thank you very much councilman
Richardson uh I will now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
please thank you chair that vote is now
showing in blue for cancers to cast
their vote
foreign
are you having the same problem
yeah um there are recommendations on the
paper 3.13.2 and 3.3 and we were being
asked to also vote for 3.4 is 3.4
somewhere else I haven't seen it it may
be my fault it may be a
perhaps could I assist in that so 3.4
um if I find my paperwork I can tell
exactly what it says but it was added in
the table papers that I think went out
the end of last week uh well not sorry
not the table papers an amendment to the
agenda
um that went out at the end of last week
[Music]
yeah I think if you read that out the
last one so um for the benefit of those
who haven't uh come across 3.4 it says
the delivery plan and subsequent
implementation of the strategy be
supported by the one one million
well-being funding agreed by the Council
on the 18th of February 2021. thank you
how are we doing yeah um
chair that is 24 28 votes for so that is
unanimous
[Applause]
I don't even have to see that as Carrie
do I really
right so we will now move on to item 16
in in the papers so this is paper MC
oblique 21 oblique four one four pay
policy report
um
so I believe that this uh
is going to be uh
uh to be proposed by councilor Morley
and
um I think uh I'd like to ask councilor
Morley before we move any further do to
make a comment
counselors as you're aware we have a pay
policy report and recommendations before
us this evening
however I'm sure many of you know that
baber District Council did not vote in
favor of these recommendations at their
meeting on Tuesday this week
whilst we are of course not bound by the
actions of baber District Council we do
have a joint Workforce and Senior
leadership team
having reflected on this over the last
48 hours and following discussions with
a number of you today I have decided not
to move this report this evening and so
I am instead withdrawing the item
this will give us more time to discuss
the issues raised in the report with all
councilors both at mid-suffolk and baber
and consider our next steps with our
chief executive head of human resources
and Michelle Kirk from the east of
England LGA
given the nature and urgency of some of
the issues raised in the report I expect
you to further decision discussions to
take place as soon as possible
and finally I would like to put on
record my thanks to Michelle Kirk for
her report and apologize to her for her
wasted Journey here this evening
thank you
counselors as
councilor Morley has withdrawn her
report there are no questions that
tabled to her on that point so we're
going to move directly to the next item
on the agenda
do you have a point of order counselor I
just wanted if we can if we had any
points on the report whether it's worth
us sending them in to anybody or whether
there are any discussions
um say councilor Morley whether you'll
be having any discussions with councilor
Mellon so any concerns or anything can
be raised that's all so I think the
answer to your question is yes
so for councilor melon to talk to
councilor morning indeed
thank you very much you're very welcome
counselor so we will move on then to
item 17 this is paper MC oblique two one
and Bleak one five revisions to internal
neighborhood planning procedures I would
like to invite councilor burn to
introduce this paper and move the
recommendations in that report
uh thank you chairman
um
we've come a long way since our first
few parishes began their neighborhood
plan Journeys
our internal decision-making procedures
have served us well
and we continue to look at how we can
improve the way we interact with our
neighborhood Planet groups
including placing greater emphasis on
the earlier informative stages
importantly though we continue to think
about what could be done better
the report before you today is I hope
self-explanatory
it looks at two key regulatory processes
that fall to this Council
the first being our decision making on
the recommendations set out in the
independent examiners report
and our advancement of that plan to a
referendum which is a regulation 17A
and the second one is subject to a
majority yes vote in that referendum our
adoption of the plan which is regulation
18a
now this report proposes changes to the
agreed procedures which with appropriate
checks in place should ensure that we
can be better smarter and swifter in the
way we guide neighborhood plans through
these stages
in midst of it to date
15 neighborhood plans have been through
the examination process
of these 11 have now been adopted and
four are in the final stages of being
modified prior to being made ready to go
to referendum
in all cases no objections were raised
by either the district or Parish Council
to implementing the examiner's
recommendations in full that would
suggest that our earlier engagement with
these groups is working
I trust that this Council will agree
with me that the proposed changes to how
we manage the regulation 17A and
regulation 18a stages are both sensible
and practical
in simple terms they would remove the
need for cabinet to specifically approve
the progression of a neighborhood plan
to referendum
and will simplify the process by which
this Council adopts a neighborhood plan
where it has received a majority yes
vote clip referendum
I therefore propose the recommendations
set out in paragraphs 3.1 and 3.2 of the
report and I asked for a second thank
you
um could I have a second here please
very happy to second that thank you
councilor Guthrie so we'll now move to
questions are there questions for
councilor burn
councilor Mansell
uh thank you chair I I don't I don't
really have a problem with the uh
proposals um put forward in this
recommendations
um but it's interesting I just wonder if
there are any plans to
um speed up some of the earlier
engagement exercises between the
district and the neighborhood plan
groups
um uh such as increasing the size of the
team of Staff who deal with it because I
certainly know of um at least one
neighborhood plan group
um who were told that there was a huge
great pile of neighborhood plans to be
looked at before any comments could be
in informal informative informal
comments could be sent back to the group
so I I welcome I don't have a problem
with these but I just wonder if you've
got any other plans to to help groups
get their neighborhood plans uh process
uh quickly and efficiently thank you
uh thank you for that question
um councilor Mansell uh very fortunately
we do have with us the corporate manager
for planning policy uh who I think is
probably better placed for answering
that question or could give you a more
informative answer than I can
so if I might ask thank you
[Music]
thank you
um
she'll answer is yes um what we've done
over the past six months we've recruited
two new members of staff to the team
who've come in at the admin Technical
Support Officer level and we've been
training them in assisting in the
neighborhood plan work
we haven't seen a sort of let up
basically last three or four years of
being very lots of work this year since
January we've had 19 consultations rank
14 or x16 we've had eight examinations
and three referendums so we do recognize
there is that need and that as you say
councilman particularly the pre break 14
engagement so that's what we're doing at
the moment and
um obviously as you'll be aware we're
currently in the joy local plan
examination hearings but some certainly
once we're free to hearings we focus on
making sure that we we do have that
engagement yeah
thank you counselor Willem
chair my question is very very similar
delegation to officers usually means
greater responsibility that falls on
those offices and more work so my
question would be can I be assured that
sufficient staff resources will be
available
councilor burn
yes thank you I I would think that um
but perhaps pubs would be as as well
placed as I am for answering that
after all he's
okay by all means
German against the bench the short
answer is yes the results will be
available but effectively what this
recommendation is what this
recommendation does is produce less work
for officers not more
thank you are there any other questions
for councilor burn
no in which case we can move to debate
uh usual rules apply so three minutes
each
um who would like to kick off the debate
okay so I guess we don't want to have a
debate
um which is fine I'm going to ask the
corporate manager for governance and
Civic office to conduct the electronic
vote in that case
cost your votes
chair that is um unanimous again 28
votes for
we will go on to item number 18 which is
counselor appointments so 18a we to note
the following appointments
um council is asked to note the
appointments to committees as detailed
on the agenda
um which you'll have
and um so that is councilor Barry
Humphries replacing councilor Dave
Muller on development control committee
a and councilor Muller replacing
councilor Barry Humphries on development
control committee B
so we don't move to item 18b check sorry
counselor yeah could I have oh sorry
could I have a clarification from Emily
uh under rule 18.1 of our constitution
cancer decisions are final and should
not normally be altered for six months
we made this decision four months ago
well I'll call on the monitoring officer
to respond
thank you chair um there is provision in
the Constitution and I'm sorry I can't
remember the exact rule off the top of
my head right now but I can look at it
in a moment that does allow group
leaders to alter membership of
committees on notice to the monitoring
officer so that's what's happened in
this case in between uh Council meetings
all right thank you for that uh so this
then takes us to
item 18b which is the election of Vice
chairman of development control
committee a
may I have nominations for the vice
chair development control committee a
please
could I have a proposal Mr councilor man
and krava seconder
uh councilor flatland thank you
councilor Mathison
Chad I'd like to propose to counselor
Sarah Mansell
do you have a second there for that
tell I'd like to Second councilman say a
few words please
thank you
I'm sorry may I say a few words oh sure
there's a proposing councilmancel I just
wanted to make the point that councilor
Mansell is an extremely professional
experience and well-respected member of
the planning committee a and a very
reliable one at that
and I think that Council should note for
the record that previous to lockdown
in the 14 months of in-person meetings
there were 18 meetings of the planning
committee and the conservative groups
candidate for vice chair
gave apologies for three of these and
left early on five occasions since the
meetings have resumed the the
conservatives applicant for vice chair
did not gave apologies for last month's
meeting no apologies or turned up at the
site visit and on the previous month
there were eight items on the agenda and
the conservatives
second left after the first item all of
this is a matter of report in the public
domain thank you chair
thank you councilor so we have some
nominations I will now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the vote
thank you chair it's my intention to do
this by show of hands first
for Barry Humphries to raise their hand
but keep it up while we count please
okay and all those in favor of counselor
Sarah Mansell
chat um
votes for 16 in favor of cancer very
Humphreys and 12 accounts
counseling
stadiums right so
uh councilor Barry Humphries is Julie
elected to the postal Vice chairman of
development control committee a
right
so now we go on to the election of Vice
chairman of development control
committee B may I have nominations for
the vice chair of development control
committee B please
councilman
thank you do you have a second though
councilor flatmer
are there any other nominations
okay so I will now ask the corporate
manager for governance and Civic office
to conduct the vote
so chair it will be the same again all
those in favor of councilman Muller to
be Vice chair put please raise your
hands
all right
so I think that's carried by unanimous
well a large majority
so uh I would like to uh
what should I do I should declare that
counselor Muller is duly appointed as
the vice chair of develop development
control B and congratulations to both
councilors Humphries and Muller
right
item 18d this is appointment to outside
body
Suffolk joint emergency planning policy
panel
could I have a proposal to appoint
counselor Morley as the council's
representative on the Suffolk joint
emergency planning policy panel
councilor Richardson
and have a secondary councilor flatben
so uh
please
awesome
um I just wanted to ask with if
councilor Morley will do a report to
council when she has her meeting on the
um joint emergency planning policy panel
because we haven't yet received any
reports from anybody on any public
outside bodies as was agreed in May so
for example we've had meetings two
meetings of the East West rail
Consortium no report meetings of Haven
Gateway a partnership no report so could
I ask that Council Morley will do a
report when she attends the Suffolk
joint emergency planning policy panel
thank you chair
chair again if we can have our hands up
to indicate whether you're voting for
councilor Morley all those in favor
please
thank you I can't I can't comment about
the others but on this one this
particular body hasn't met yet and I'm
very happy to do a report at the
appropriate time
the oblique 2-1 oblique one six these
are decisions taken by the chief
executive under delegated powers in
accordance with part two of The
Constitution
so I would like to invite the chief
executive to introduce the report which
is for noting
thank you Jim and I'm going to delegate
it to the monetary officer I think he's
practically prepared to report on it I'm
right here
thank you chair and I will be very brief
as this is just for noting um the report
details three decisions taken by the
chief executive under delegation they
relate to the making of three
neighborhood plans in I will be and
drink Stone and the reason that they
were taken out of meeting was in order
to impro to comply with the statutory
deadlines that are required in terms of
making those neighborhood plans thank
you chair
thank you very much so
item 20 motions on notice so the first
motion on the 20a is to consider this
the the motion on notice received from
councilor Pratt
councilor Pratt would you like to move
your motion
yes thank you chair I'm really delighted
to be moving this motion
um
and uh forgive me for starting off on a
cliche
um Starry Skies Inspire Aura and wonder
and they are a magical site that brings
stargazers and astronomers into the dark
locations of our Countryside to seek
their connection with the cosmos
um however light pollution prevents us
from observing the sky at night it is
the result of artificial lighting at
night time particularly the lighting
that shines or scatters upwards into the
sky producing what is known as Sky glow
over our towns Sky glow reduces our
ability to view celestial objects that
would otherwise easily be seen in the
contrasting backdrop of Darkness
in some places artificial lighting
essentially turns night and day
Street lighting is no longer just a
feature of urban Landscapes with new
developments and changes in the way that
we use the countryside our village is an
open country are becoming more brightly
lit
climate change alongside other
environmental and economic concerns and
pressures have less has led us to
replace conventional lighting such as
high pressure sodium lamps with LEDs on
the basis that they are more energy
efficient
in addition to producing an intensely
bright light however nearly all LEDs
emit higher levels of Light Within the
blue region of the light spectrum than
their traditional counterparts
unfortunately this increased light
intensity in the shift in spectral
composition towards blue light has
impacted Wildlife particularly bats and
nocturnal insect populations and can
cause harm to human health and
well-being
so lighting so it is said can improve
the feeling of safety for drivers and
pedestrians
but there are also negative human
impacts to consider Studies have
suggested that direct exposure to light
at night time
can have serious health implications
it can particularly affect our body's
hormones that are responsible for
maintaining sleep patterns and there is
also evidence which presents a direct
link to the development of some known
cancers including thyroid cancer
we are to also consider that light
entering private households can also be
seen as a real public nuisance
we understand that biodiversity is in
Peril some estimates predict that one
million species or 40 of all insects
will become extinct over the next few
decades and peer-reviewed studies
demonstrate how artificial lighting at
night has common tributed significantly
to the insect apocalypse
this is because illumination not only
causes disorientation in insects but
affects their natural biological rhythms
that control things like foraging
migration and reproduction that are
normally synchronized with daily monthly
or yearly light cycles this is really
catastrophic implications for insect
populations Studies have shown that
artificial lighting at night are
extremely disturbing to bats as well
because bats of water avoid light and
change their foraging paths and delay
their emerging from their Roots missing
some of the peak time for foraging for
insects
so taken together we must acknowledge
the impact of lighting
the impact that lighting is having on
human health and the environment so in
our July 2019 meeting mid-suffolk
District Council acknowledged the
accelerating rate of expeces extinctions
by declaring a biodiversity emergency
and we pledge to bring forward proposals
to take action to protect and enhance
wildlife in the district
to achieve this goal we cannot ignore
the need to mitigate insects of the
declines in relation to artificial
lighting
or conveniently LEDs can be engineered
to emit lower levels of blue light using
Color filters and we could look at into
using things like true Amber or phosphor
converted Amber PCA LEDs but brightness
can be reduced
remotely and progressively dimmed
through the night lamps can also be
timer and controls as sensor controlled
so that they come on for shorter periods
of time or only absolutely when
necessary Shields and baffles can be
also fitted to reduce Sky glow and
prevent night light from entering
households
other councils have already taken action
to reduce the impacts of lighting in
Wildlife sensitive areas especially so
for example worst Worcestershire County
Council installed bat friendly lighting
along an a road nearby local nature
reserve the street lights are designed
using Color filters especially to admit
light that does not that affects the
natural sensors and rhythms of bats yet
which provides enough illumination for
residents helping making the road and
Pavements safer while being highly
energy efficient their lighting does not
compromise visibility for drivers and
pedestrians and is said to be fully
compliant with the required standards
you have 30 seconds thank you similar
lighting schemes have been tested in the
Netherlands improved successful in
reducing light pollution impacts on
Wildlife so today our merging councilors
to acknowledge the detrimental impacts
of artificial illumination at night on
human health and nocturnal wildlife
our Council can take action to ensure
lighting schemes on all new developments
meet the best environmental standards
where practical we can apply tighter
controls on outdoor lighting in our own
buildings housing stock and public Realm
um I'll just quickly finish up by saying
in doing so we will show that we both
care for the health and well-being of
our residents and we account for
biodiversity we show that we are a
council that is adaptable in the face of
emerging issues in the never-changing
world of information I invite you to
support this motion
and as far as I know become the second
Council in Suffolk to commit to reducing
light pollution thank you
thank you Council of Pratt for sticking
to your time
[Applause]
uh could I have a seconder please
counselor Fleming
right we're going to move to dube8 now
uh counselors will only be allowed to
speak once and for three minutes and
this will be timed as normal
um and uh who would like to kick off the
debate
Council Fleming
thank you I wasn't sure whether I was
going to get a spot
um I won't speak for long because I
think my colleague
councilor Pratt has said um you know a
lot of most of what's important but I'm
very happy to be seconding this motion
um and um I just wanted to to say a few
things that um it's going to fill in the
gaps
um as has been said
artificial lighting has serious
environmental consequences of humans
wildlife and our climate
and light pollution takes the form of
glare which is excessive brightness
causing visual discomfort
Sky glow or brightening of the night
scale the orange glow we see over towns
and cities like trespass flight falling
which is not intended
and clutter bright confusing signage for
the most part
now most of us will have heard recent
news about the effects of artificial
light on Wildlife do I have a time limit
because I had a bad Assurance yes you do
you've got time I've got time okay I'll
try and rattle along
um
about the a BBC program and recently in
particular about the effects of
artificial life on wildlife and not just
bats but also in particular insects
another species such as amphibians birds
mammals and plants
and also some of you may have heard Lord
deepen's recent interview on radio
Suffolk with Mark Murphy where he
Advocates no artificial lighting at all
in rural villages
and Reliance on torches
now most of us will take that with a
slight pinch of salt but I do have some
sympathy for his message
it is important however that we as a
council understand the implications of
artificial light
and take steps to control it
so how do we go about doing this
but we have committed to Preparing a
supplementary planning document
to increase the protections for
biodiversity and Wildlife and we're also
considering preparing a design code
which would translate the intents of the
new nppf
to improve Tranquility in the natural
world and Beauty in particular now
having engaged in some initial
discussions
left 30 seconds right it is clear to me
that there is a lot of scope for
improving the lighting schemes that we
deliver within this just this District
I recognize that there must be balance
between natural background and the human
desire for safety but I believe that
much greater weight should be placed on
local sensitivities and it is time to
review this subject and add protections
against slight pollution so whatever
means are available to us thank you
thank you councilor
so
um right
I think given the time constraints
I would like to move to a vote on this
particular motion so I'm going to ask
the corporate manager governance and
Civic office to conduct the electronic
vote please
councilor Manson
um but I mean I understand we have to
leave the voted by 10 even if we have
the vote now I don't believe we've got
time to to discuss fully the other item
on our agenda anyway
um and I'm sorry I thought you said that
we did have we were allowed to have a
debate on the other thing and I just I
didn't realize that councilor Fleming
that was her final summing up I thought
she was just part of the debate so um
but fair enough I'll
be quite a few members that might want
to speak on this we not defer it to the
next meeting because otherwise we're
cutting short topics that are worthy of
discussion
I'll ask the monitoring officer for our
price
thank you chair um yes members you have
a choice at this point you could choose
to adjourn the meeting and the remaining
two items will then be held over to such
a point as we can convene another
meeting of the full Council
or you could try to condense your debate
and obviously there isn't a lot of time
to do that given the ambition to be out
of the building by 10 o'clock thank you
thank you councilor Hicks I'd like to
propose a journey please
do we have a second
Council Humphreys
Okay so
we
sorry I thought you'd already moved to a
vote and if our members moved to vote
then we need to vote and you've already
said that before um
before this conversation started and I'd
be happy to move to a vote
okay so I I understand where you're
coming from councilor eberne I perhaps
was a little bit Hasty in my judgment I
think that in the light of the the
feeling in the room I think we should
actually respond this to the next
council meeting
sure
um thank you very much if we are going
to adjourn there are two items left on
the agenda can they this meeting has
been so long because we didn't have a
July meeting and we we did ask that
there could be another meeting another
meeting scheduled after July so please
could we have a meeting scheduled next
week then a fortnight in a month and not
have a long Gap again because that this
is what happens we just get a build up
of things that need discussing and it's
not very Democratic to leave that for a
long period of time to have a really
lengthy meeting and it's not fair on
offices either chair
uh councilman
yeah thank you chair I wasn't entirely
sure from the the members opposite
whether the the controversial issue was
this motion that we were just starting
to do today or the one that we may have
gone on to which probably we won't go on
to now
have both
well I think the uh the intentia council
lady is that we will restart again with
this motion and and then the other
motion uh at the next meeting
oh yes
okay
chairman just in terms of rescheduling a
meeting
um we will work with the chairman to
find a suitable date as soon as possible
um I obviously we need to ensure that
there are five clear working days so
it's unlikely to be next week but um we
will work on that as soon as possible to
arrange a date where we can return to
these items
thank you so I think at this point
councilor Mansell
um yeah can I just clarify that that at
a uh another meeting whenever that might
be scheduled that these two items are
the at the beginning of the agenda and
not right at the end of the agenda
I don't think I've with this an issue
with that but I'll ask that monitoring
officer to comment
so that is entirely possible
um of course it might be a meeting
solely for the purpose of these two
items if there isn't any other business
ready to come forward from the work plan
okay so uh could we then now please move
to a vote on the adjournment
um can we do that by a show of hands yes
we can uh right all those in favor of an
adjournment
I think that's unanimously carried uh
right so just
um first of all let me thank every every
each and every one of you for uh your
attention during the course of this very
lengthy meeting this evening and and
your contributions to questions and
debate as well as my gratitude to the
officers for their support and guiding
us through the meeting and indeed of
course the advisors that came to play
their part
um as as we've just said we're going to
look at a date for another meeting but
currently the next date is tabled for
um Thursday the 25th of November
2021 at 5 30 and this meeting is closed
at 9 54.